jay leno
he's apologizing because the woke have
come for him you see he used to make
jokes about asian people
and he knew in his heart it was wrong
it's really amazing you know we've seen
these stories about
these comedians we had that one woman
ellery smith she's a writer with robot
chicken
where she just comes out and tweets that
she's a violent racist as if that's
going to make her job prospect get
better
and she also made disparaging comments
about asians it's funny because i
brought this up probably a year or two
ago
when we're talking about critical race
theory and bigotry and all this social
justice stuff i'm like man these people
sure do love to make fun of asian people
well now critical race theory is coming
back for them because the rules
which aren't solidified i guess
changed and now all these people that
thought they were in
you know on the right side and allowed
to do what they do you know everyone in
the crowd was doing it so they did it
now they're getting canceled jay leno's
scared he's gonna lose his job so he's
like i admit it i knew it was wrong the
whole time
that's what i don't get like you want to
apologize for being racist or whatever
fine
but to come out and be like i always
knew what i was doing was wrong that's
crazy because why would
anyone want to work with work with you
after that now i get it jaylen was
retired but
we're gonna talk about this we're gonna
talk about cancel culture we got a bunch
of other you know ridiculous stories
dollar shave club
apparently announced that they're
shutting down their magazine and i'm
like
i wonder what kind of magazine this is
apparently it's a men's magazine but
it's like super woken anti-masculine
it's no wonder they shut it down
get whoa go broke jay leno is gonna
gonna reel from this because now he's
admitted
he's always been a racist
congratulations jay you're a racist
that's your legacy from now on
joining us to talk about these issues in
cancel culture and comedy is comedian
aaron berg how's it going man
good how are you pretty good uh so
what's your deal you're a comedian is
that it i'm a comedian i have a show
on compound media and it is called in
hot water it's monday to thursday with
the brilliant ginobisconti i use the
word brilliant very loosely
and i also have a patreon show called
gum fridays on fridays and i've been
doing stand-up in new york city
for almost 10 years i've been doing
stand-up for 20 years
uh i'm extremely funny and 20 years
yeah so so you probably made the same
racist jokes as jay leno
more on behalf of jay leno i would like
to apologize
well hold on i'm asian so i'm allowed to
laugh you guys have to shut up thank you
yeah
racist wasn't funny uh it wasn't fun i
opened on saturday with i go i'm
exhausted i have been killing
asian masseuses all week and i am just
wiped out oh and two others but nobody
cares about them because they weren't
asian
wow that's a brutal commentary in the
media though
yeah yeah why don't they care about
those two people they don't care about
chicago
they don't care about what's been going
on in chicago every weekend for the past
year no
but that's a typical talking point it's
been going on for more than the past
year right right
and shootings we thought were going to
take a curb because of covert but they
haven't shootings got worse
yeah but i mean at the same time there's
mass riots and they're calling for
defunding the police so
all right we'll get into this we'll save
it for the conversation but uh you know
ian's
hey everybody ian crossland here though
hi aaron nice to meet you
too man this is great it's it's so fun
to be in this nondescript location
which is like very well hidden out and
i drove here and it took all day and it
was raining
and i go why am i doing this and then i
got here and i was like
yeah and i go this is why is because of
those hot dogs we had
this is really funny we're gonna we're
gonna do live events here and one of the
events we're planning on doing is a
chicago event
yeah and so we're going to fly out
probably like a thousand dollars worth
of pizza
uh and hot dogs and it's funny because
barack obama there's this email where
it's like he had a party
in dc he hit a party at the white house
where he flew out like 30 grand worth of
pizza and hot dogs from chicago
and the conspiracy theorists started
telling everybody that it meant children
right when quite literally chicago has
lou malnati's giordanos and portillo's
hot dogs
so we actually you you can get
portillo's hot dogs overnighted they're
very very famous it's a very famous
aisle you get sports peppers you get
celery salt you get a big old pickle and
tomatoes
and it's chicago's got it it's famous
hot dog and it's uh it's got its famous
maxwell street polish
so i'm like yeah we're gonna we're gonna
fly out pizza and hot dogs for this
event and then
like make fun of the conspiracy theory
you know yeah people are gonna think
that you're this incredible leftist that
has this pedophile ranch
in the middle of nowhere oh no and i
think we're making fun of them
you could also because of chicago
weekend just bringing a whole bunch of
gang bangers to shoot each other on your
back forward
it'll be just like it'll be phenomenal
it sounds like we're going to get in
trouble on this episode
why i i thought that i was treading very
lightly
i think you came out with a bang all
right all right so uh ladies and
gentlemen i'm also in the corner i'm
going to laugh my tail off tonight and
i'm going to love it it's going to be
awesome all right well before we get
banned from the internet yeah we gotta
sponsor today and it's
it's it's biotrust i'm extremely excited
for this go to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can
secure your supply of biotrust ageless
multi-collagen
up to 51 off while supplies last we
actually have it right here
ian puts it in his coffee so good you
know
all the time actually he's drinking it
right now it's creamy and i put it in
smoothies collagen for those i don't
know it's an important protein for your
skin your bones your joints
so you know being a 35 year old
skateboarder and trying to exercise
i take that seriously i'll make
smoothies protein shakes and i
definitely love this biotrust stuff
but they uh they got a bunch of really
important things they want me to tell
you about
go to strongerbonesnlife.com you'll find
the link in the description below
60 day money back guarantee they say the
five key types of collagen
you need from four different sources
hydrolyzed collagen peptides meaning
better and faster
digestibility to support maximum
benefits for every order today we donate
a nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor
through their partnership with no kid
hungry.org to date
biotrust has provided over 4.4 million
meals to hungry kids
please help biotrust hit their goal of 5
million meals this year
it's non-gmo and free of artificial
colors flavors preservatives sweeteners
free of gluten antibiotics and rbgh and
rbst
no odor no taste unlike bone broth or
other collagen supplements no clumping
free shipping with every order and this
is really awesome you get free
vip live health and fitness coaching
from biotrust's team of expert nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order that sounds amazing i know they
afford that
that's that's really great and a free
new e-report the 14 foods for amazing
skin with every order so seriously
in the description below you will find
strongerbonesandlife.com check it out
pick up your collagen and
shout out to biotrust thank you for
sponsoring the show and don't forget
if i can find where the mouse is go to
timcast.com
to become a member and get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim gastero podcast
we had jody shaw yesterday we had
chrissy mayer the day before
and typically in these exclusive
segments you'll hear
a robust array of a variety of
profanities
from the people not always but we do
swear more and we say things that
youtube doesn't want us to say and i can
only imagine it'll be a particularly
spicy
members-only segment tonight so go to
mps.com become a member but let's get
into that first story
the story about jay leno he says
according to the daily mail i'm in my
heart i knew
it was wrong jay leno apologizes to
asians for
decades of jokes that promoted
stereotypes and were made as recently as
2020.
they say media action network for asian
americans
waged 15-year campaign to end the
remarks
the comedian says at the time he
believed the jokes were harmless
comments continued until last year when
leno cracked about koreans eating dog
meat leno says the apology is not the
result of cancel culture
but a legitimate wrong that was done on
my part
it's amazing i mean that's that's the
gist of it apparently he offended
numerous people on the set of nbc's
america's got talent
quote at the time i did those jokes i
genuinely thought them to be harmless
leno said during a recent video
conference with m-a-n-a-a
i was making fun of our enemy north
korea and like most jokes
there was a ring of truth to them what
wow wow wait wait wait wait wait
he's like i apologize for making these
offensive statements that were true
they were true wow that i love it
is jay leno actually just you know
taking the piss trolling
felt like they were harmless but he knew
in his heart they were they were wrong
he says i was making he said i genuinely
thought them to be harmless
he says i knew they were wrong he says
like most jokes there was a ring of
truth to them
you talk wow i know it was wrong but i
was absolutely right
i'm saying this and it's not like i went
after south korea they still have the
internet
so i wouldn't attack that wow i kind of
feel like did we
maybe get punked by jay leno and he's
just laughing all the way to the bank
now like he doesn't care he's retired i
guess
he's super rich he's just trolling like
uh tatyana mcgrath right now
he's just like fake apology i i get it
you you could feel bad about it you know
leno is
a typical edgelord if you remember i'm
joking he was never
no he was known for toeing the line as
much as you could totally
late night extremely never touched his
tonight show money
every cent he made all in the bank lived
off of his stand-up of money it's
really it's a very well-known fact but
you can't no one called him out for it
so i get that you feel badly about it
but keep it to yourself
and make a donation you don't have to go
out and throw yourself
under the bus what's his show that he
has now it's about cars or something
right yeah i don't know but i can't
believe he said that
i'd like to apologize for making these
offensive jokes which were true by them
no no so there's another quote he says
whenever we received a complaint there
would be two sides to the discussion
either quote we need to deal with this
or scrum i can't take a joke
too many times i sided with the latter
even when in my heart i knew it was
wrong
leno says the apology was not the result
of pressure from so-called cancel
culture
that has drawn complaints from from
others whose comments came under public
fire for actions or statements
lana said the apology was the result of
a legitimate wrong that was done on my
part you know what man i'm i'm offended
i'm offended right now i think what jay
leno is saying this apology is extremely
racist to my
to my family to the and i i mean this
sincerely
it's patronizing yeah when he makes a
joke about a despotic
you know authoritarian regime in north
korea good
screw him like these are the north
korean communist party or whatever they
call it
kim jong-un these are bad people they
put people in gulags for
thought crime right we do not like the
authoritarian garbage we like the idea
that we can poke fun at each other and
treat each other as equals
because that's what it is if i can make
fun of you you can make fun of me we can
knock each other
down a peg or two we get it it's jokes
right jay leno coming out
he's not doing it he actually cares he
he made these jokes
recently all of a sudden now he's trying
to act like he's not you know being
racist or whatever
i actually find what he's doing to be
the racist it's more racist because he's
clumping all
asian people together because he feels
bad about a shooting
where six asian women were killed and he
saw his friend go down for the robot
chicken thing or whatever happened
but he's it's it's the flavor of the
week
this week this is the flavor of the week
i'll tell you what offense what if what
what what i find offense about the whole
thing is that
they only started caring not not even
because of this this event that happened
in atlanta they don't care about that
they care because the tide shifted in
the the woke cult and now they have to
you know move
with the the hive and so that's it they
don't know about what happened they
don't care about the news
all of a sudden they heard oh you're
going to get in trouble because there's
a protest that says stop asian ain't
like oh okay i'll pretend to care now i
don't think jalen who cares is jay leno
really going to get in trouble
i mean he's at that he's at that level
of rich
where you're not going to make a dent in
it and i think that there's this
i push all the time to me there's
there's nothing sacred i can joke about
boulder today i could joke about a
muslim guy
in a racially motivated attack killing a
whole bunch of white people
i can joke about it the media says
that's not the case yeah well i'm not
the media i'm a truth-teller
oh no i'm just saying like there's
there's a narrative you know yeah
and i know what the narrative is and we
witness that narrative so i i think that
we take in some of that group think that
even though we have these beliefs
we still take in the real liberal left
soft we're wrong we need to make the
world a better place and i get it i've
battled with it too but that's how you
know you're good person because you go
oh should i be doing this and you go
yeah i should because comics
comics deal in negative currency we
attack racism we attack homophobia we
attack transphobia
and we make jokes about all of it right
you said your favorite joke was that
classic chappelle thing from
a year and a half once it's my favorite
joke it's a damn but
chappelle when he squinted his eyes and
bucked his teeth yeah
like dave chappelle on one of the
biggest comedy specials
only a couple of years ago did a 19 was
like a 1920s style
stereotypical yeah yeah yeah and was
what was the joke like like but this is
how i feel
yeah and he did the accent he did
everything and
i'm i am so uh grateful to dave
chappelle for doing that joke
it's because well it's because remember
what's his name shane i think shane
gillis is yeah
he he said a word we're not allowed to
say on youtube
but he was accusing other people of
saying these things right he was like
these other people say these bigoted
things like this
and apparently they like some other
times in the show they had done like
asian accents or whatever
like mach ones he loses his job over
this
and he was actually being semi-critical
of other people like he was pointing out
something someone else does
dave chappelle literally did it yeah and
they all just said thank thank you dave
that was very funny
and i'm like okay good yeah look man we
need to be
we need to be able to make fun of other
people i do think that
there are limits to reasonable you know
good faith efforts at comedy
like there are some people i think just
try to make everyone offended and not
actually
make any points but those aren't the
funny comics right right there's a
handful
of really good comics in this world
currently and it's probably 50.
and that's including england and they're
long-winded storytellers but there's
still something
really relevant to the craft that they
do but what we do
it's negative currency we take all this
horrible stuff
and it the end is positive when you come
to a live show which you will or if you
bring us here for a live show on chicago
weekend because i would come for pizza
if it's a cheat day and then when you
have
when you see the way these people laugh
and i'm not talking
giggles like the stuff that i do in new
york in front of the most diverse
audiences in the world
has people holding their stomachs
laughing so it's a negative thing
that has a positive end i've i've seen
jo jo
rogan's show yeah in philly and he goes
after everybody
he's he's really good spirited about it
he's not like it's you get it i've seen
dave chappelle special and i grew up
with george carlin yeah george carlin
has got some spicy bits to say the least
and people used to cheer and clap for it
because we understood i guess
you know i don't know what changed but
now you've got these puritans
that somehow formed on the left that
just want to cancel people
and the problem is there's this weird
marriage between
establishment media digital advertising
and then when the wokeness cancel
coaching stuff came in it latched on to
this
establishment media so now because of
that
all of these people people like jay leno
will just be like tell me what you want
me to say and i'll say it
that's basically what they're doing so
they're abandoning their principles
or or showing us they never had them to
begin with or they're showing us their
absolute cowards
and they don't care to to actually stand
up for
true classically liberal values freedom
of speech freedom of speech
you know progressive thought right yeah
you know you know it's really crazy i
was listening to
um i don't remember
i was listening to that eminem song i
think it's called without me
not entirely sure that's what it's
called but what's really fascinating
about older eminem music
is that it was very topical and
offensive and controversial
so like he's got that line where he's
like you know the grammys try to bring
bring him there and he's like why
because you guys just lied so you can
get me here
sit me here next to me britney spears
christina aguilera better switch me
chair so i can sit next to carson daly
and fred
fred durst hear margie over who she to
first you know we'll keep it family
friendly a little bit
but uh that was a popular song where he
was calling out a female pop star
for going down on a couple of other
celebrities
and that was a hit song everybody was
loving it they were laughing it
i guess christina aguilera did a diss
track against them and i'm thinking
about that song where he's like we need
a little controversy it feels so empty
without me
and now we have the story where
apparently like they're trying to cancel
eminem
you know like the gen z has been
complaining about him being a bigot and
stuff and saying offensive things of
course he said offensive things it's
eminem do we think
yeah and he made a song called like you
know cancel me or something
it's not very good in my opinion but
whatever and i'm just it's it's
interesting now
how much things have changed and how we
have this generation that grew up on
south park on family guy and eminem and
all these shows have become puritans
and then you get like i mentioned the
establishment is scared
they bend the need of the stuff digital
advertising gets scared they bend and
bend the need of this stuff it's a it's
a dramatic transformation in only like
10 years
you know what i mean it is but you're
also aware of
how much ebb there's been and how much
uh the plates have shifted
that you don't really need advertiser
dollars anymore that you can
you can make your own way you look at
you know other comics that have done it
they build their own audience
they go out on their own it's it's meant
to be
controversial if you're not in trouble
you're not
doing anything or saying anything but
they'll try and shut you down
for something totally unrelated if you
if you were
spewing this rant on why you think kovit
wasn't a real thing and that it was
you know to do something else
politically uh
they would disagree with that but they
would try and shut you down for
using a slur for a little person or
something yeah
cuomo cuomo gets caught trying to cover
up
the death of 15 000 people due to his
policies
he put sick people in his nursing homes
he was warned by the nursing homes
you're going to kill people and he said
do it anyway
and then they call for his resignation
because a handful of women came out and
accused him of inappropriate behavior
and i'm like you know it's tough do am i
happy
that they're calling for a resignation
because he's a bad guy who's got to get
out
or is it bad because it's just the ends
justify the means they ignore
the atrocity and they're like but don't
you slight women
that's it that's it right people won't
come after
the thing that really offends them
because they know that they will lose
that argument so instead they look for
these other little thorns in your side
so it's like if i've done transphobic
jokes or anti-asian jokes
that's what people come after because
they know that the product
is oh here's an hour of making people
laugh hysterically
we can't argue with that but we can
argue with hey you can't do that asian
joke that you did two years ago
that's what they just want to pick it
and my belief is that people that really
try and
cancel comics is to negate those people
out of the way
to open up have you ever seen woke
comedy yeah
they try and cancel me they'll tag clubs
it's horrible it's it's
unwatchable there was no no but hold on
hold on it's like it reminds me of uh
you watch futurama have you ever seen
drama i've seen it
so they there's one episode way back in
the day they crash land on an amazonian
planet
populated by all of these massive like
10 foot tall super ripped women
that's racist and race like sexist
and so the amazonians are explaining how
they have basketball and no canned dunk
but good fundamentals yeah and so like
they're they're kind of making that joke
as well that it's like
it's not entertaining to watch but it's
the right
you know but you're so you have to
support it because it's the right
ideology right
yeah so you have these comics it's awful
unwatchable i watched a special from
vice on what comedy and it was really
sad i saw that
it was sad it was the person making fun
of themselves the whole time and i was
like dude this is depressing me dude
like i'm not laughing i feel bad for
this person it's like i'm gonna go out
and i'm gonna like i'm gonna go ride my
bike get exercise because that person
depressed the hell out of me yeah like
hearing them just complain about how
miserable their life is
the old rule is tragedy plus time
they want to take the tragedy away and
just be like
here's the time yeah and it's boring it
is
and and but it's it's it's like
buzzwords
though it's clapter you know yeah like
they'll get up on stage and be like
those white supremacists they're bad
right yeah there's a lot of
white people bashing now i haven't seen
it that much in the past year because
comedy's been either like
illegal and taking place in speakeasy
environments or outdoors
illegal the only real people that have
been doing it are the people that are
ballsy enough to go out and be like hey
i don't care about this thing that
killed 500 000 people allegedly but i'm
gonna go out
and uh just do comedy and that's why the
audiences
are also more right wing now so they're
more willing to laugh at stuff well
they're all gonna come out
yeah this is the crazy thing so we had
uh chrissy mayer
yeah i watched yeah and um i think she
brought this up for the subject came up
where
you have all of these leftists who are
scared of covet they don't want to go
out
all of these urban environments where
they've shut everything down because of
covid
so what's left conservatives are willing
to come to your show
not necessarily conservatives but people
who aren't scared are willing to come to
your show right and you can do it in
more conservative areas in red states
where they didn't lock everything down
so these left-leaning individuals or
whatever you want to call it
corporate democrat types politically
sheep whatever are in their apartments
doing nothing
not going out comedy clubs are being
shuttered and then comedians are
doing jokes for conservatives yeah you
know where you're more where you
actually have your
your business still exists think about
what's going to happen when when all
this finally gets lifted and who knows
when it'll get lifted for the blue
states because the red states are
already opening up
they're going to be stunted by like a
year market wise
you are going to have way more
conservatives with savings
with money because they're in business
yeah they're going to get a year
advance on all of these left-wing you're
going to get a bunch of liberals working
for conservatives
they're going to need a job and who's
going to own the jobs the conservatives
yeah and you go online
all the conservative comics are like hey
i'm in omaha this weekend hey i'm here
this weekend hey i'm here
all the liberal comics are like when's
that stimmy coming through
and they're just waiting for that stimmy
and they still call it stimmy i don't
know so
we were talking before about advertising
and
uh how you don't really need it right
right i think
but let me say this seems like a great
product
and a great company that gives back to
people
and genuinely cares about people yeah
yeah yeah for sure i mean we have a
handful of sponsors but uh
what i mean is there's this there's this
uh interesting
overlap between digital marketing and
entertainment and the resistance the
anti-trump democrat types and the
wokeness
and so that's why you see every major
brand change their logo to a rainbow in
june
because they're like this is what people
like but
most people probably just shrug and say
i don't know whatever you know what i
mean like that's cool i guess it's not
like they're actually going to make more
money by doing this
so it's interesting that these companies
that tow that woke line
think it's the right path forward it's
not going to make a money
and i have a story for you check this
out this is from business insider dollar
shave club
has laid off all of its staff at men's
lifestyle site
m-e-l source says and is looking for a
rescue buyer
now on the surface this doesn't sound
like a get go broke story but i assure
you it is they say
dollar shave club is laying off staff
the staff of mel magazine
its men's lifestyle and culture website
a person with direct knowledge of the
matter said
mel staffers were informed of the
layoffs on wednesday the publication is
seeking a buyer and many
and many i'm sorry and may face shutting
down if it doesn't find one
it was unclear how many people were
affected mel's masthead lists about 20
people plus 16 contributors they say
after six years of successful
partnership and transforming the men's
health and media spaces for the better
you see that mel and dollar shave club's
financial relationship will come to an
end in 60 days
editor-in-chief josh skollmeyer said in
a statement he added
mel will stop publishing effective
wednesday and the complete focus will
now be on finding the right new owner
this has always been a part of the plan
for our brand-backed partnership and
we're incredibly proud of what we've
built together
you got you got to take a look at this
one very important point
they say transforming the men's health
and media spaces for the better what do
you think that means
transforming it for the better it means
making it
less mail yes uh getting well look at
this
go to mel magazine.com and the the
headline story do i have to no the
pressure to
act like a man starts in preschool boys
as young as three
are more than happy to police the toy
box and make sure that no little dude
walks away with a barbie
i don't care what does this have to do
with men show me an article where it's
like eating
eating steak and fish will make your
muscles bigger something stereotypically
dude-like i guess
that's the thing give me three-year-olds
on testosterone replacement therapy
and then i'll agree with you then they
have uh they have this one down here
there's finally a name for trump's
murderous masculinity
who are they marketing to women frail
low-t
liberal men who can't grow beards first
of all to say
that trump is a vision of masculinity is
just incredibly misleading
tiny hands possibly fake hair
tanning lotion on the face he's just
like
an out of shape masters level
bodybuilder at best
like coming in at 60 thinking he looks
good in the mirror and then he steps out
on stage
against real bodybuilders he's like
trump's thing
a lot of things but what conservative or
trump supporters coming out preaching
about trump's masculinity yeah
no not once no no no like i've heard
talk about you know working-class
populism
protecting the worker borders national
security but i've not seen that group of
like staunch
wearing guys being like trump is our
vision of masculinity there's like
pictures of him
artwork where he looks ripped i have
seen those with the hawk behind him
i love it when ben garrison draws trump
because he makes them
yeah you know super ripped and like
strong but i think they all kind of get
the joke of it trump is an
old he's an old man and he's very out of
shape yeah and i'll tell you this
i'd be willing to bet that compared to
your average person in this country
donald trump
how can i phrase this properly it is
extremely unlikely likely that donald
trump has ever had to walk a mile
um i mean look he's been he was born
into wealth
he he's rich i'm sure he's walked you
know he golfs right so i'm sure that
he's walked periods he rides
most of the time but he well now as an
old guy but i'm sure i'm sure
you know at some point it's like he he
did walk a mile i'm not saying he never
did that would be ridiculous
he doesn't have to right and so whereas
a normal person might be like i gotta go
to the store and i gotta walk and carry
a cart with me
trump walks outside there's a car
waiting for him it's probably always
been that way yeah so he's not a vision
of of masculinity
i will say this he's
what's the right word for trump i don't
want to say like he's a tough guy
no no like aggressive maybe he's
aggressive and arrogant mentally let's
say he's masculine
sure maybe mentally maybe that's what
they're trying to say
but i don't i don't even i don't even
know if i agree with that
i'd say he was i guess i guess if you
say aggressive behavior and arrogance
i mean i think to be a success in
business you have to have
a i don't know if it has see to
determine a masculine mentality is wrong
it's just uh the idea of grift the idea
of innovation the idea of cutting deals
those are traditionally associated with
male values but they're not you can see
by the success
that uh female business owners have it's
something that can be
emulated so success in business can be
emulated so
just to you know bring it back to the
core issue i guess
there are certain things that men
stereotypically like
and i suppose the argument from these
these brands is that we know we
transformed it for the better
because men shouldn't be masculine it's
toxic or whatever
i guess it's their attitude they didn't
transform it for the better nobody was
reading their magazine and they're
they're losing their principal sponsor
that funded them
because nobody wants to read this stuff
look i don't read men's health
you know and there's a there's a bunch
of channels there was one we did a
segment on um
i can't remember what we're talking
about we're talking about men not
getting oh no we're talking about the
tri guys
you know the try guys no so this was a
group of dudes at buzzfeed
and they got their testosterone levels
checked and their testosterone levels
were lower than that of an 85 year old
man okay nah that's sad i'm like i'm not
trying to write wreck on these guys i'm
like dude
if you if you go to the doctor and you
get your t levels checked and they're
like yo you're 25 and your testosterone
is lower than that of an 85 year old man
you might have a serious problem
yeah i don't know maybe cancer or
something there might be some serious
hormonal imbalance prostate possibly
and and so everyone's making fun of him
like nah that's a medical issue dude
it's not a joke i can't believe they
published this story but
we had this one guy he's got a youtube
channel it's called i think it's called
more plates more dates yeah seems like a
cool dude he was like actually
adding the conversation he he runs the
video and he's like there's some good
points they made i thought it was i
thought it was great some criticism some
constructive criticism
and but a lot of the comments were
ragging on us you know they're
like oh these guys don't exercise don't
work out or whatever and it's like like
i have two skateparks in my house i go
to skate like almost every single day
i should lift i suppose but i i look at
this these conversations and i wonder
i think that the split here is there are
these people that believe
in constructivism and then there's
essentialism and the constructivists are
like
we can make a men's magazine telling men
that they should play with barbie
and they'll want to read it right and
then there's masculine dudes
who lift and are super ripped talking
about how great they are
you know and making fun of us or
whatever because there are things that i
think guys tend to be into
i think the issue is look there's some
social construction like constructivism
sure but i think dudes have testosterone
i think they have more fast twitch
muscles they have more bone density more
collagen
and there's a reason and guys are
probably going to be predisposed to
certain activities
when you make a magazine built against
all of that
don't be surprised when you collapse
they're trying to go
against nature and be like here's what
you should be
and you're saying naturally a man is not
supposed to be that
i don't you know look it's hard to say
naturally
you know um but that's kind of the gist
it's more like
a tendency right you know men have a
tendency in a certain direction towards
certain activities
like the the guys have high testosterone
which means they're going to build
muscle mass faster
prenatal testosterone results in more
fast switch muscle development which
means they have more burst energy
can sprint can jump can run faster you
can see this all in scientific data
so why would you make a magazine
critical of all of those things
that are physically you know ingrained
in
men people are trying to jump on this
thing where they think it's the right
thing to do and they think it's going to
succeed but your old catchphrase get
woke go broke
is so applicable in so many forms i
haven't seen
anybody okay successful comedian patton
oswald he's woke
but he wasn't always no he was edgy for
years
and then now i mean what's he done
lately he's he's he's still working
it's around i think he's like you know
he's a
step in the hollywood cog he works he's
there
i don't know if you know a lot of comics
are
fans of his and then there's you know
because he's successful yeah
he's also got these horrible rumors
surrounding him obviously
but it's like i think that happens with
anybody that gets any modicum of success
there's nothing inherently wrong with
masculinity
but i think we're being fed that there
is you're a masculine guy i think
i think there's tremendous positivity in
masculinity i think masculinity is a
tremendous and amazing thing
and i'll tell you there's one thing that
proves it
the demand and the desire from feminists
to make women more masculine
that's how so they'll well they they
want so if you look
at traditional gender roles between what
is masculine what is feminine
the men were the hunters the gatherers
the the athletes the soldiers
feminists want women in combat they want
women as ceos they want women in the
military-industrial complex
they want women's sports to get more
prominence you got megan rabino saying
we fell stadiums we deserve this money
they want more prominence for female
athletes doing physical activities which
are not traditionally feminine roles
you can argue that gender roles were
wrong sure
that's that's fine make that argument if
you look at
the traditional gender roles you can
argue they're wrong i want to break them
down
and so that means the things you are
encouraging of women are traditionally
masculine
you think those things shouldn't be just
traditionally masculine but you are not
advocating for men to be more feminine
or i should say for the most part
there's where's the big
you know billboard announcement or like
magazine cover story about the ceo who
quit like racist kids there are stories
like this
for sure but i mean like we constantly
hear about the new female ceos we
constantly hear about women's sports and
women right
we keep hearing that women need to enter
the world that was traditionally
masculine that was traditionally a male
gender role
and they say it shouldn't be that way
okay fine argument make the argument
we'll talk about it
where is the equal and opposite reaction
saying men shouldn't be in the workplace
men should be at the home with the kids
that's something that men should do
because think about it this way
no one is saying men should leave the
ceo position
men shouldn't be in the workplace men
should
like where where's the magazine that
says men belong in the home with the
kids
you know men should be doing this when
they talk about women and the role of
women and wives and and girlfriends and
things like this
they say women should be ceos
they say men can be homemakers but
they're not saying they should be
homemakers
right so whatever it is that men have
traditionally done
things associated with masculinity
physical activity combat
being the ceo they want women to do and
they are at the same time
not giving the same amount of energy to
the traditionally feminine roles of
nurturing
like you gotta you gotta think about
this too like when you think about what
femininity is
i'm not gonna pretend to be an
anthropologist or a sociologist but i'll
say
men my view of like man it's like a guy
running into a burning building to carry
out the kids and save their lives
men go and and hunt the you know the
wild boar or whatever to bring food back
for the tribe
they get the job and they go out and
they go on dangerous missions and there
is that uh
i guess there are many people who refer
to it as male expendability
and this is because of you know women
have children and you only need one man
you know to reproduce but you have many
women then when you look at traditional
femininity what do they do
they create people they literally
gestate them birth them and then raise
them and still them with values now
fathers do this as well
but the mothers are the builders of of
people in society and
and cultures that's what feminine idiot
feminine femininity is and it's
extremely important
and i think it's fair to say when you
see many traditional uh
you know commentators will say the
mother's role is in many ways more
important
because you need that nurturing role to
be there to protect and grow
people that's being left behind and
ignored
i wonder you know is it an issue of
encouraging people not to have kids and
families because of overpopulation
or why it is or why it emerged i
honestly don't know but there is a
tendency right now
to disregard the the traditional
feminine role in society while promoting
the traditional masculine role
that says to me that society greatly
favors masculinity over femininity and i
disagree with that
right i i think part of becoming
masculine
and embracing that is that when you get
to a high enough level of that
you achieve this level of okay i'm
confident enough with where i am as a
man as a provider
as uh you know somebody that supports a
family
that then okay now i can let this these
traditional aspects of femininity into
my life where i can help take care of my
kid and i can do all this stuff
so i think that it's an evolving too
people don't want
equal rights nobody wants equal rights
people want
extraordinary rights i i think that's
what the attempt is when
when i watch uh you know when you
see some experts of of blm or some
experts
of feminism it's like okay this is not
about achieving
equality it's about achieving a higher
up status
that's what i see when i look at it from
the outside absolutely
it's it's it's power yeah and i think
there's a lot of people especially the
woke people who have found a path to
power lies in victimhood
and that's hence you see the oppression
olympics
and then you see just ridiculous
businesses
and attempts to make money off
controversy
and uh make tv shows that are overly
woke and it's just awful
victimhood is a currency for them for
for comics in the business we had a
woman that
you know our fans made a joke about and
then she's like ah these are rape
threats
they're coming to my house to it no one
ever did any of those things someone
made an off-color
joke and her victimhood helped propel
her
to the next level i mean she used to
have 5 000 followers she's got 60
000 now then she'll make a a joke about
i hope trump dies or something and then
uh then people go after her and she'll
be like oh but look what happened some
guy called me
uh dyka am i allowed to say that no not
on youtube but
i i really curious like
i constantly hear from these journalists
that they get emails like these female
journalists get emails from guys who
call them awful names and say you're
awful fake news
and they use all the slurs in the book
and i'm like i wonder who writes those
emails
you know what i mean like you get this
female journalist you work to the new
york times
and then she posts a screenshot saying
here's an email i just received
and i'm like dude i get emails i get to
i just don't post them yeah i get death
threats
i don't post them they but they know
because currency and they're on in their
tribe
because then we're hypocrites if we post
them we go hey look someone just
threatened it
literally i have a screenshot of someone
saying it would be really funny if
uh some of your loved ones died and i
know who the guy
is i know he's a real guy but i don't
post it because if i post it
then people are like well you should
take it you're a big bad comedian you
should be able to take the death threats
but the other side
is not supposed to it's it's yes and i
also think
so where's the equality or is anybody on
the side of freedom
maturity going to be like i'm so sorry
for you oh let me let me
donate to your gofundme because someone
said mean words they're gonna be like
why are you posting this
yeah like you know we we know you're
strong enough to be resilient towards
the stuff
and you know we don't care yeah on their
side
the way it works is there are there's a
there are large swaths of people
who don't know and don't pay attention
right so here's a really good example we
had jody
shaw on the show the other day right are
you familiar with her story she works at
she worked at smith college
and she quit and filed a complaint over
hostile work environment because they
kept
you know criticizing her for being white
and telling her to talk about her race
and
negatively impacting her job based on
race and she was saying how she didn't
complain about it at first because she
just thought it was normal and why
people don't complain about this stuff
and then eventually she realized it was
really eating away inside
and that she couldn't stand being
attacked based on race and she did
something about it
so what happens is that that that first
part of the story she told where she
said you you just supposed to accept it
you're not supposed to complain about
this
this is what these these journalists and
these these cancel culture people make
make their the social currency off of
regular people who aren't paying
attention to politics and don't know
they hear a story about a journalist is
getting death threats from trump
supporters
poisons the well for trump supporters
then there will be a trump supporter
saying like
you know a reasonable rational guy with
a maga hat and they'll be like it's you
you're the people doing that and it's
because these individuals have no idea
what's going on
don't read the news don't follow the
culture
and then they're fed these stories they
just believe them the weapons work
now for you you don't have access to the
new york times platform
so you posting that screenshot won't do
anything for you
it does everything for them because they
have access to legacy media and
these powerful institutions which is why
i tweeted earlier i think i found a
solution
to uh help unify the left and the right
okay i think we can get the bernie
sanders
supporters and the socialists and the
trump supporters and conservatives
together
in the same room if we just propose one
policy change
taxing hollywood millionaires and
billionaires and
legacy media millionaires and
billionaires at 90 of their income
because then the leftists are like tax
the rich i'll take it and the
conservatives are like oh the hollywood
liberal types and the media
do it that's a good idea i've always
advocated for tax the poor
i think that taxing the poor is a great
way to get home
people to hustle you know pick yourself
up by your bootstraps tax the poor
and it's a great hoodie too well that
you know bloomberg actually proposed
that
did he michael bloomberg uh said poor
people spend money on stupid things
i'm paraphrasing and he was like so you
tax them and then we can
better spend that money for them yeah
i think that is insane okay
first and foremost the first part i
think is true
for everybody people buy dumb stuff yeah
like dude
i look at like these yachts from these
rich guys and i'm like why you have that
come on elon musk is doing it right what
did he do he bought a spaceship
yeah right on brother he's building a
spaceship and electric cars
the yacht of the skies they call it but
there's a functional purpose to
scientific research towards going to
mars and
it's helping all of humanity this
research he's doing then you look at
some of these other billionaires and
millionaires and they're like i have a
large boat
it's like okay i guess it's nice and
comfortable it's only free but that's
buying something dumb
right and then you look at these people
who in the lottery and they buy like
golden statues of themselves
yeah it's like why would you do that i
guess you got to put your money
somewhere
but a giant these are lottery winners
you see the people that
go in yeah people buy them tickets
you're like
oh these people win the lottery well in
recent history people who in the lottery
have learned
and started hiring wealth management you
know wealth managers and things like
that
the point is it doesn't matter if you're
rich or poor people buy dumb things yeah
so bloomberg has a good point in that
poor people are buying dumb things
but bro you want to be the despot to
tell people they can't buy
a sandwich they want to eat that's nuts
that's and he did it he wanted to ban
large sodas
yeah his idea was remember that we take
all their money away and then we give
them what we
know they need yeah sure like food
stamps ebt cards that type
is that if people knew that they were
being
say you you're at a minimum wage job
you're making let's say you're making 14
an hour in a grocery store not minimum
wage uh and then you know maybe you're
making 26 grand a year but you're in
this lowest tax bracket
and 50 percent of that goes to taxes but
if you get to 35
000 they're gonna drop that rate to ten
percent
but it only works for the money above so
like
the first thirteen thousand dollars i
think is tax-free yeah
i think you still gotta pay like
medicare tax or whatever then from 13 to
35
you're you're it's like 12 then from 35
to like 100 something i think or to like
80 it's like
21 and then it goes up to 30. so you're
not actually losing money by making more
money right a lot of people think that
but what i i do think
for uh what's the saying it's like only
47 percent of americans actually pay
income tax
yeah and that's because a lot of people
are the poverty level where they don't
actually
have to pay anything or they get a
refund back from like the money were you
poor
ever super poor well i was homeless
several times yeah yeah i'm from the
south side like real homeless or like
sleeping on friends couches like
sleeping on the street
slept in the street a couple a park
couple times
but uh typically in a car yeah and then
you know it's rough man because there's
a funny thing about being 19 and being
homeless in that
if you had a place to live a lot of
people have no problem with you falling
asleep on their couch
but when they know you don't it's all of
a sudden yeah that's weird almost
something very similar yeah so it's like
i had an apartment
i'd be at someone's house on a friday
night or whatever and i just we watch a
movie and i'd pass out i'd wake up and
they'd be like yo we're gonna go to
breakfast
when i was homeless fall asleep on a
friend's couch wake up like bro you
can't keep doing this yeah and i'm like
keep doing it dude i fell asleep twice
yeah so there was one point where i
worked at o'hare and you could sleep in
the airport
you weren't supposed to but because
there are shifts you know 24 hours a day
when i worked for you know so that
that's how i avoided for the most part
sleeping outside yeah
super poor making almost no money doing
back breaking labor was not
not easy and not uh wouldn't recommend
it i had it when i was
like 15 and i had was out for two weeks
and would sleep
at friends houses in the basements and
the projects and stuff and then i
started to get my stuff together
but there was years where when i first
moved to the united states and it cost
me 30 000
to move here from canada legally and get
a green card and all that stuff
and i was in this fifth floor walk up in
harlem
where the projects were right next door
and the people in the projects had
a better life than i had
where i was living and it was just
there's something
motivating about that but i don't know
if it's because my education
or because where i came from or the
people that i looked up to that it was
like i got to do better than this
i i guess i had good parents so yeah you
know we
we went through hardships life wasn't
easy and uh we
you know my family we lost our family
home when i was like 13 or whatever
but uh i had smart parents who
understood what hard work was
i had a mom who was very idealistic and
my dad was very realistic it worked out
for me
but this brings me to uh what you
mentioned about moving here
the next story we have check this out
city of oakland mayor is branded racist
for giving families of color 500
a month if they earn under 59 000 with
no rules on how they spend it
but offering poor white families nothing
oakland mayor libby chef announced the
race-based program to give families of
color 500
monthly checks half of the 500 grants
will be to families earning under 30
000 in the predominantly bipark east
oakland area now
a couple important things to point out
for one it's privately funded
okay so fine if somebody has a million
dollars and they say i'm only going to
give it to people i want to give it to
welcome to private exchange of wealth
that's
okay there you go the city is
implementing this though so i have
questions about the legality even if it
is privately funded
but the other thing is they say bipac
you know what that means
uh i'm gonna guess correct me if i'm
wrong black and indigenous people of
color
yes and do you know what do you know
what there's two minority groups
missing from that bipod uh
jewish canadians oh all right well i
guess if you want to get really
technical there's a lot of people
missing from
asians latinos but but
asians have been elevated asian people
are the next white people
yeah it sounds like a mouthwash
[Laughter]
so look man i wouldn't qualify for
something like this
right and you have people in this
country who are not even white who would
not qualify for something like this
this is where things start to get start
getting twisted they talk about
reparations this ain't reparations this
is literally being like
just not for you white person so you you
told a story about how you move here and
you're you know you're
would you consider yourself poor when i
moved here yeah i i was you know you
don't you don't qualify for any help
sorry yeah i know because of your race
okay we've judged you we we know well
isn't that racist
sir quite literally is the definition
yes racist okay so can
can you fix it and can i then get
reparations because i didn't get
reparations
is that what we're gonna do is it gonna
be another 50 years and then we're like
all of these programs and all this money
that was spent
was racist therefore reparations for
white people yeah i think
we we knew this was coming in this
country you
knew this right i knew this look you
need to understand
my family was experiencing all of this
critical race theory stuff when i was a
little kid
coming from a mixed race family i think
there's a lot of white suburban
you know and like uh there's a lot of
white people who don't realize
this stuff has been happening for a
really really long time right and
it was in our faces you know what i mean
so uh look my dad's white and there were
there was anti-white sentiment with
affirmative action and things like that
in chicago
and so he would get told that he was
wealthy and privileged for being white
meanwhile
he's in a mixed-race relationship which
is extremely rare in this country
oh by the way that's a sign of racism i
don't know if you caught uh
bill burr the fact that he's married
that's right woman makes something nice
now apparently i didn't know siraj
hajime said that guy was a troll
and yes but there are many people who
have already said that i i was at uw
in seattle and one of these woke guys
was arguing to me that mixed race
relationships
particularly with asians especially with
asians was a sign of you know fascism or
whatever
because you know germany loved the
japanese and i was like you're a [ __ ]
yeah just i just don't even know where
to begin but uh you know growing up
and having my family be like i guess i
guess we could say lower middle class
but then we ultimately ended up losing
our home
to a bankruptcy it's really interesting
to be in a family where it's like
you know some sometimes our fridge gonna
be empty or we're eating like steaks
from dominic's that are like
particularly cheap yeah and
my family does the best that it can but
we're by no means rich and then
you know my dad gets told he's not
qualified for a promotion or things like
that because he's the wrong race
so you mean to tell me that we have the
civil rights fight
loving v virginia to make it legal for
inter to ban miscegenation laws right it
was actually illegal before 1967 in many
states
to cohabitate with someone of a
different race isn't that crazy wow
1967. yeah it's not even that long ago
man no
i feel like sodomy was legal in more
states right probably
yeah and so you actually had this period
where like my
my mom and my mom's side of the family
are growing up literally at a time when
they had to flee different states
because
it was quite literally illegal yeah well
congratulations civil rights uh
protests worked and now here i am and
now i'm
told depending on my ideology i don't
fit in i don't qualify for their special
programs
and and i try to explain to people
listen i'm the last person in the world
who's going to complain about my
identity and be
like i demand this because i'm
marginalized for this reason but i will
point out your hypocrisy
and your short-sightedness what these
people don't realize when they talk
about the bi
uh the black indigenous people of color
communities
the indigenous community has a community
the black community has a community
the latinos have a community the asians
have a community there's no like
mixed race meeting groups where you
share your common cultures
in fact koreans are extremely racist and
they're not forgiving
so you grow up in this environment where
the only thing you actually have that
that you you
you know you find yourself surrounded by
is americans i grew up in an area where
you know
people of all different races all
americans so there was no
issue with race now we're entering this
world where they're claiming they're the
champions against racism
and they're quite literally making it
worse for everybody especially the ones
that the civil rights movement fought to
help and it's amazing most of the people
that are
against racism are also anti-american
definitely and when you when you say
that there's this unity between people
that just
no matter what race they are hanging
american flags outside their home
you're just like oh everybody's going to
get along here no matter what's
happening
because they believe in the country the
thought came into my head
literally this morning and we haven't
heard it for
years because it didn't exist during
trump's presidency
remember the old love it or leave it
quote that people used to say all the
well you love it or you leave it and
it's like
that is so far gone now because the
country's gone through such
turmoil and separation it's inevitably
gonna change
there's no going back to that life
liberty pursuit of happiness love it or
leave it i don't
think so i think that he was the closest
thing that they were gonna get but
uh trump's egoism probably kept us from
that
uh but i don't think it's gonna happen
it's not gonna happen under this
presidency
i mean joe biden's awful for a lot of
reasons and i think
donald trump was an imper i call him the
imperfect avatar of the
of the national populist rage that they
were feeling the establishment was a
crooked
is establishment politicians it are
crooked corrupt crony politicians we've
done it for a long time
we saw the the occupy protests you know
now almost 10 years ago people in this
country were fed up with the revolving
door policies
some guy works for halliburton and also
he's the vice president
we knew how the game was being played
and we snapped and said enough
and you had a split you had left
populists who are like we need social
programs and welfare and
and socialist policy and then you have
the right laissez-faire more capitalists
things like that
many moderates and then you end up with
donald trump and he was the one strong
enough to
smash the door down unfortunately he's
imperfect maybe ron desantis in 2024
will
will be much better and more tactful and
better embody
that anger from you know many of the
american nationalist types
bernie sanders came out recently and
denounced the the permanent suspension
of donald trump from the social media
platforms that's a good sign yeah
and i'm hoping that we can we can find
certain things to agree on because
the the you know the trump supporters i
think recognize this to a certain degree
they have more in common with bernie
sanders supporters and these
progressives than they do with the
democratic establishment
sure the problem is many of these
progressives will vote for a
for a corporate democrat before they
ever imagine voting for
a right-wing populist because they think
they're fascists
that's what that very that's the bear
that's gonna be broken down where it's
like look man
my my policy positions my ideals i took
the political compass test
i'm even further left than i realized on
the political competence it was crazy
yeah cause i'm like tax the rich and all
stuff and i'm like how about this
how about we tax the hollywood rich is
that something conservatives would agree
with i think they probably would
i think it's it's a fun idea for when
you run for office
i'm not going to twitter never no way
come on no
you know i i will you know you can kill
a whole bunch of old people
then you can just go flirt with women
and nobody cares
i like to touch your face hey i'm
italian
whoopsie i'm italian
is that racist or are we allowed to talk
about italians because
you could just put the trouble to me i
just showed up here you could just say i
just dropped into your house
i think it's like it's almost like
hillary clinton and donald trump were
extreme versions of themselves or the
ideas of what they represented
like trump represented the anger from
right-wing populists and the america
first types the people who want this
country
to to actually use its tax dollars to
support this country
then you get trump trump is is like he's
almost
america incarnate he's a loud arrogant
boisterous capitalist yes entrepreneur
so america like what what what did obama
say you know in his
in college the american dream is to be
donald trump hillary clinton
was like it's really amazing if you were
to if on a scale of 1 to 1
to 10 of representations of things
you know in this country donald trump is
cranked up to 11
yeah in terms of like how much he
embodies this kind of american
exceptionalism
his president goes to 11. right and
hillary clinton
when you want to embody corrupt
corporate crony politics
she was cranked up to 11 as well yeah
and trump barely won that one
joe biden they cranked down a little bit
and then i guess you know that was
enough for him
i don't think he knows what he's doing
and i think but
hold on hold on i'm sorry yeah when you
say i don't think he knows what he's
doing
do you mean to say like as president or
just at any given moment at any given
moment tim
he doesn't know where he's standing he
has no idea what's going on
him walking up the plane steps was just
so funny
uh he has no idea he he's a puppet
for that party and they it would have
been awesome
to see bernie sanders run against trump
i think that they
they could have used that extremism
bernie i i i don't i don't know if
bernie would win now because of critical
race theory
but i think bernie would have won in
2016 hands down yeah nine million people
switched
from voting for obama in 2012 to voting
for trump i like the notion of desantis
because
when you're an immigrant and you move
here you
embrace american ideals although
somewhat antiquated so
our version of america was when reagan
was president when i would watch tv and
you'd watch the news and i was in my
early teens and you're like that's where
i want to live
i want to live where you can say trickle
down economics that's where i want to
live
and there was this beauty of it and
scarface was around that time and there
was just this
notion of the american dream and that's
what we kicked the
doors down to have we didn't want to
kick the doors down and be like
no no no no you're white get to the back
of the line and i've heard it
numerous i was up for a comedy central
thing first year they go you're perfect
but we got enough white guys second year
no really like oh how long ago really
uh i i did ari shafir's show and it was
called this is not happening
so this is maybe four years ago and now
comedy central
is the wokest you can get you remember
broad city kind of trailed them off
and now they're just doing bar shows
with 20 people and
horrible woke comedy but they told me i
had this story
where i i'm going to say it as clean as
possible because i don't want you to get
in trouble
i pleasured myself in front of two men
for a hundred and fifty dollars and
at climax uh the man said i want it on
me
but i didn't want to go over there
because that was to
uh fem for me so i threw it at him and
that was
that's the whole bit it's a 15-minute
story
it's it's brilliant offensive like it's
brilliant
you can't tell it clean it's available
on comedycentral.com you can watch it
it's like
a hot chocolate story it's a real story
i was a stripper for like a summer and a
half
and uh and this story was perfect for
this thing it was this long-form
storytelling show
about stuff that you can't believe
happened this is not happening then
second year i submitted and ari's a
friend of mine he goes you're great
but they really need uh women of color
they're looking for
so they would download that that
happened to me advice yeah and then
fusion
and then year three he goes you came
really close but they already had enough
famous work and then i was at a mets
game and someone called i guess someone
dropped out
like can you be in la saturday and shoot
this and i go yeah but
i i've had it happen to my face where
because of the color of your skin
not the content of your character you're
denied something and the problem is
what is it 66 to 70 percent of the
country is white
is it yeah that'll be significantly less
in what 20 years
it will be i think in 20 years it'll be
something like in the 50s like by 2050
it's going to be you know what when like
white people become
a minority they'll still be the
plurality and then we get reparations
you know i i think my issue with it is i
actually like the idea of representation
you know you know i talk about this
quite a bit when i can't remember what
happened
uh some marvel movie was coming out i
think it was black panther when black
panther came out
i saw it four times did you like it i
did not want it really no
oh you didn't see it no yeah i thought
it was great is it great yeah
there's there's a line where t'challa
the king of wakanda goes we cannot allow
immigrants into our country because
they'll bring their problems with us
and i was like whoa whoa that's like
super trumpian yeah it's in the movie
we must build a wall they have a wall
they literally have a wall
that keeps everyone out of their country
right did they say this we will make
wakanda great again
did they say that they totally said that
they didn't need to because it was
already great
did they say this oh look at you sleepy
joe did he say that at any point
okay but the the so but i was commenting
on the movie and i was like listen
they did iron man white dude they did
thor white dude captain america white
dude
i got no issue with the color of this
guy's skin right but i do
recognize that sooner or later there's
to be a movie it's not a white dude you
know what i mean like
they got to make movies for everybody in
this country that people can enjoy and
they do it right
when they don't beat you over here with
the ideology and just show regular
people doing regular things right
right but now they're beating us over
the head with you right right right i
think i can't remember who was who was
here and we were talking about this
saying that like you know uh for every
show you're allowed like one teaspoon
of like social justice or like ideology
so you're watching a movie it's a horror
movie and it's like a vampire is
attacking people
and then they make like a passive
comment about redlining in urban
environments or whatever
yeah as they do oh i just ate some red
pilled blood
the vampire like goes to a poor
community and they make a reference
yeah the point is if you're watching a
movie and they make a social commentary
a little bit is fine and we recognize
and go i see
but now what we're getting is literally
the whole movie itself is just a social
commentary so there's no story there's
no
plot it's trash get woke go bro exactly
i i thought uh i thought black panther
was actually good
there was a lot of social commentary in
it but i thought it was good because
t'challa was like trump
i mean not in the sense of his attitude
i mean chitalo and his and his and his
physique
t'challa was super ripped you know he's
thinking it was more masculine than
donald trump
much more masculine than trump but like
to see the argument
where they're talking about how these
other african nations are doing really
really bad
yeah and wakanda is doing really well
t'challa's literally like if we let in
immigrants they bring their problems
with us with them
and i'm like he's supposed to be the
hero for these leftists
he's the the black representation that
they were cheering for and here he is
saying
something that should offend them but
they cheered for it because the ideology
was more important to them
than what he was actually saying i
thought it was i thought it was actually
really well written is that because the
power corrupts
that he starts out with these great
intentions and then you get he does open
up in the end
yeah but he he then goes to one of the
but i love this
seriously you guys got to watch this
because here he is
in sub-saharan africa in wakanda and
they have this gigantic wall it's an
invisible barrier that not only stops
people from getting into their country
but or into their capital city i suppose
whatever it is but they also can't even
see it
okay erase it they don't want anybody
they're super xenophobic he says that
line
we can't let people in they'll bring
their problems with us at the end of the
movie when he finally decides decides to
open the country
does he go and help these other
sub-saharan african countries
no he goes to oakland he goes to the
wealthiest country on the planet
and he goes to one of their wealthiest
states and he goes to one of the biggest
cities
he's got his problems and he gives
resources to the people there
i'm like that's a profound statement
when remember when they accused donald
trump of saying something like we don't
want people from these you know ish
whole countries yeah
we want them from norway or whatever
that's literally what they had to child
to do
yeah instead of being like okay we're
finally going to open up let's
get people from you know the zimbabwe
and south africa to come to our country
he goes to oakland he goes to the
country he goes to the united states
where there's prosperity and wealth
he was still in the end extremely
classist
it's remarkable to see that especially
remarkable to see how
they don't like these woke people don't
recognize exactly what was wrong with
what t'challa was doing
yeah based on their own ideology let me
ask you this if
the actions trump took
were done by a black president
would it have had the same blowback
for the left for the country as a whole
and for the left
the problem with that question is is he
a black republican or a black democrat
because you know if he's a black
republican the black community is going
to call him a certain word
well do it all the time all the woke
people all of them the entire if
it it it's not this is what's really
fascinating would it does it confuse the
woke people
because they want to have those thoughts
and say oh this guy's uh this guy's a
xenophobe this guy's a bigot
oh but he's black oh okay is that gonna
change the argument no
and that's uh a kind of it's a really
interesting thing
t'challa and wakanda from black panther
had a lot of trumpian policies
and they loved it not only that check
this out the movie
shows that in wakanda you become the
supreme autocrat of the country through
patriarchal
ritual combat that's their political
process
people loved it yeah so even though you
have a guy who you you should be
despising based on what you
purport to support they loved it
if you took a democrat a white old man
joe biden they'd vote for him and they'd
claim that he wasn't racist even though
he's got decades of racist history
passing all these laws that are like
criticized for being racist not anymore
joe biden's the only president that's on
camera saying the n-word twice
donald trump won a bunch of awards first
did he win like a couple awards for
civil rights
i know he did he's in these photos he
was like parks he's the first person to
hire a woman to like build a skyscraper
and now he's you know they say racist
sexist anti-gay donald trump go away
it's like donald trump is the first
president in american history to support
gay marriage before becoming president
yeah he unfurled a rainbow flag at like
a republican convention or whatever
and got the rnc to clap and cheer for
the lgbtq community
like that was trump but they call him a
bigot barack obama
comes in blows up kids in the middle
east american citizens
they disappear gone they don't care
obama can do what he wants because he's
a democrat
joe biden will get elected and they'll
sing his praises because he's a democrat
when they complain the republican party
is the party of white men
the rnc had several black people speak
what did the left say
they didn't praise the republicans for
finally doing the right thing and trying
to diversify
they said tokens yeah an extremely
racist comment
about legitimate individuals with good
policies and good ideas
that are worthy of argument accomplished
individuals and that's that that's why
those people make me sick
because they're more racist than the
other side
oh these these great black highly
intellectual politicians that are well
spoken have great policies formulated
for their areas
they're only talking because you need
them up there they're tokens
that's exactly what they say it's so
hypocritical
and our job is to call out that
hypocrisy but when you do
then you're the racist well this is
what's funny there's a tweet from glenn
greenwald
i don't know if you've seen actually let
me see if i can pull it up because i i
posted it on instagram
and uh i will in fact pull it up and i'm
ready i'm going to expand on this uh
this this tweet from glen
great tweet glenn greenwald tweeted if
you think the real power centers in the
u.s are the proud boys
4chan and boogaloos rather than the cia
fbi nsa wall street and silicon valley
and spend most of your time battling the
former while serving the latter as
stenographers
your journalism is definitely ish
he's correct yeah so expanding on that
why is it that you know we rag on
democrats or like iran
democrats all the time because they're
the power structure in this country
the republicans don't do anything mitch
mcconnell is awful impeach the guy for
all i care he doesn't do anything
he's not helping trump supporters he's
fighting trump supporters he's not
helping the republican party he is
fighting against the people who actually
helped republicans win
in 2016 and the ones who did in 2018 and
2020
even though they did lose position a
position in 2018.
mcconnell and lindsey graham actually
hurt them right lindsey graham is seen
going on the
the you know the senate floor and like
fist bumping kamala harris when he was
supposed to be challenging her on a
bunch of policy issues
he's the republicans don't help republic
republican voters democrats are tribally
supported for the most part and
i think it's fair to say republicans and
democrats get tribal support but the
democrats
actually do things they're proposing new
bills gun control
look at all the new gun control that's
that's on two new bills where's the
republicans putting up bills to rescind
gun control
right they don't do it they don't do
anything so when i when i when i've been
looking at all this i remember i was
talking to my mom about this
and my mom was saying like you do talk
about democrats too much and i was like
okay what the republicans do this week
i don't know what the what the democrats
do oh the democrats were doing xyz yeah
the republicans aren't doing anything
right what am i going to say mitch
mcconnell did nothing again he's
obstructing oh that guy
the action that's taking place is what
you want to talk about but when you look
at the media
they're still obsessed with trump
and with republicans yeah and and the
rhetoric
coming out of their mouth that that the
democrats help
feed the stuff white men or the
terrorists in this country
it's why is nobody going after ahmed
so yeah well now they they changed their
tune real quick it was really funny
there's this one woman she's like
she's like obviously we all know it's
going to be a white man a maga guy
and then when the news came out she was
like let's not focus on the identity of
this individual because
that will just glorify and then when
people are like yo you're a hypocrite
yeah she said something like don't you
realize that even if he is muslim he's
still white
like she had to like trip
did she did she set her twitter to
private yet that's what i always liked
to watch
listen it's yeah okay
is it syria's in asia make sure i got my
geography correct
let me ask you this shouldn't uh
shouldn't
biden be getting blamed for this because
of bombing syria
yes yes a lot of so why isn't he
look man this is why i highlight this
glenn greenwald tweet
it's why i call out the power structures
there's a reason there's a double
standard we know who has the power and
what they're doing with it
joe biden bombs syria and then a couple
weeks later
some guy from syria who's a loner and
messed up
goes off the rails is there a
correlation there
they're ignoring it yeah they ignore all
of this stuff but they draw their own
correlations whenever they want if this
was trump this would be eight days of
don lemon crying
and then uh cuomo's uh other brother
taking naked pictures outside of his
house in the hamptons
to try and deflect this country
here's the problem and by the way i like
being able to sit and talk without
having to be funny and uh just do fart
jokes all day
but let me say this this country
strives to be progressive but it's not
because everything that gets done the
next president tries to undo
this country will be fully functioning
and damn near perfect when both sides
own up to the bs that they throw
and we're on an equal level playing
field if people held biden responsible
the same way that they held trump
responsible
there'd be a lot more happy people and i
think biden should have run on like a
maga type thing but
m-a-a-a make america america ah
where am i i'm confused what do you
consider yourself politically
i first of all i can't vote because i'm
not a citizen yet
i did do the test and it turns out that
i am a quote-unquote core conservative
core conservative that being said uh gay
marriage
i believe in uh my my things that made
me
lean to the conservative were that
immigration should be done legally
because i did it so it's people bring up
with me like well just because you did
it doesn't mean that's how everybody
i think you should have been able to
just walk through 90 miles of desert
without any
it's mostly snow up there i would have
to snowshoe i'm saying you should fly to
mexico and then walk in
oh yeah that works and hire a coyote in
canadian dollars
and then they just throw it away
yeah i don't i don't speak spanish i
just what is that where's the y
watch i got more uh porque esta no
donde good you're not speaking spanish
i think it is my my friends will tell me
it is yeah so
anyway that i was very pro gay marriage
uh i think
taxation led me to be like the fiscal
stuff i was conservative on
and then the immigration stuff and that
and it was just like some weird
internet thing that we filled out on the
show and they're like oh you're a
core conservative can you name uh how
long have you been here in the u.s
nine years all right so can you name
some republican politicians you think
are honest
should we play the jeopardy theme
i can't really say honestly i could say
people that i like and that i would like
to see
you know you don't think rand paul is
honest oh yes i do
yeah but i think he's also come around
because he was such a fringe player for
years
where people wrote him off but yeah now
he's great uh
desantis i like and i like the attorney
general
that spoke when they had to have a black
guy speak for the republicans and i want
to say barr but i'm not sure if that's
exactly who's the senator from south
carolina tim scott i think so yeah
the black people uh i'm not a big fan of
most republicans
like i said like mitch mcconnell the
fact that that guy just retains a party
leadership position
is he is one of the biggest roadblocks
for republican voters these are
dinosaurs that are so instilled in the
system
it's like look i did a joke and i don't
even know if i can do it here
i said old white men are not necessarily
the best leader
for a progressive nation and then i say
boy i don't
even know if i can say this joke the
fact that i'm doubting it how about how
about we save this stuff for them save
this for later remind
me only when we're allowed to remind me
to tell you about the two people running
for president
because the fact that i'm doubting it
means that you may look at me
really weird after well so i like to do
this thing where i ask people like
can you name an honest republican yeah
and
people usually give an answer it could
be because of the bias that our guests
have you know leftists don't want to
come on the show but
then i ask people can you name an honest
democrat and everybody's like
oh definitely not like i mean i think
bernie sanders is a little honest i
don't know
what was it honest when he went up on
stage and said if you're white you don't
know what it's like to be poor
when you're white you don't know what
it's like to live in a ghetto maybe was
it honestly maybe that's honestly what
he believes
because he's a rich white guy well then
was it was he honest when he dropped the
word millionaire from his speeches the
moment
he became a millionaire from selling his
book did he he stopped saying
millionaire he says
the millionaires and the billionaires in
this country so then he just changed it
to the billionaires
yeah he's pretty smart i was pretty
honest removed it all right i like this
i'm gonna buy his ice cream now i guess
he brought it back
saying millionaires he just cut out
millionaires
and just goes to the building there was
an article you're right because the
whole
national conversation changed to
billionaires on twitter like almost
overnight
how many billionaires the us really have
look man you got 999 million dollars and
you're flooding politics with it i got
problems with that
yeah you're a billionaire doing the same
thing i got problems with that elon musk
what does he do he's building a
spaceship all right he's all right
you keep you he we don't we don't well
taxi elon musk you can keep your money
because he's building spaceships i think
the richer you get
and i'm not going up against your uh tax
the pedophile movie star thing that
you're coming up with in this weird
group chat
but i think that uh yeah i think rich
people should be given a break
why do you think so like but to find
rich because now i've i'm i'm not rich
but i i
work don't take my money stop texting
the thousand days
and the millionaires i work hard but now
it's like the harder i work the more
money i have to pay in taxes
and i think i should be given a break i
think people should go hey aaron you've
worked hard
enjoy it i tweeted tax the rich
then i tweeted tax uh hollywood
millionaires and billionaires 90
yeah and that is basically like i think
conservatives will agree because they
don't like the hollywood
nobody does because they think tom hanks
has an ankle bracelet on and he's like
in a deep face
it's because you get p you get these
celebrities who use their money to
negatively impact politics that they
don't know
they know nothing about for virtue
signal points right so conservatives
don't like that when you see people like
alyssa milano coming out and using her
resources to just
negatively impact the country then the
leftists are like tax the rich i don't
care who they are they shouldn't be
doing this they shouldn't be flooding
you know politics into the zone but
anyway
i want to make this point there there's
a few things i tweeted and also these
leftists are like shocked
i tweeted the trans flag with a with a
with a rifle on it
and it says defend equality and then i
tweeted under no pretext
shall the right to keep and bear arms be
infringed i could there's there's two
sentences
the leftists like to say under no
pretext
and that's a quote from karl marx who
said under no pretext should arms and
ammunition be surrendered
right the workers should frustrate this
by force if necessary
for for americans there is the right to
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed
and i'm like hey we agree on this right
boom
combine the statement all these leftists
are like shocked like it's like no dude
you don't understand there's like these
statements are tribal signifiers and
they mostly offend people without anyone
actually understanding what it means
do i think that transgender individuals
should have ar-15s
of any caliber and style they want to
defend their rights yes
should the black panthers be able to
march around with their guns
the constitution says yes 100
good honest law-abiding americans who
want to protect themselves from
tyrannical government
from criminals just protect their
families allowed to do it
and so it's like these leftists are
surprised because i think they don't
realize
how much right-wing individuals and
populists are not fascists and would be
like dude take your guns please protect
yourselves we want you to
yeah and when i say tax the rich i'm not
saying a dude who makes
200 thousand a year or 400 000 a year
and i know many of the leftists do say
that i'm saying
i think about george soros the
conservatives complain about him all the
time right
okay well you also got the mercers the
koch brothers you got tom steyer you got
bloomberg
you've got right and left and it tends
to be many left-wing and authoritarian
you know
ultra-wealthy who are flooding the zone
dumping money into politics
to subvert the rights of the working
class be it left or right
tax them i don't care i do think there's
a problem in just giving
that money to the government because
they're not going to do good things with
it either then it'll blow up kids in the
middle east
right but i wonder if we start by taking
away the influence of special interests
can we then start to chip away at the
government to regain
some control by getting rid of the
millionaires and the billionaires and i
mean the people with half a million like
half a billion or more
in terms of millionaire yeah i i think
you can take that influence out but then
you need to reshape everything and not
go
towards a military industrial complex
and put money into education and money
into
poor neighborhoods exactly exactly
that's a challenge my wife tells me that
all the time
i'm like tax the rich but the only
problem is when we do the government's
gonna take that money and then go
gobble up kids and they're not gonna fix
you know infrastructure so yeah
that's that that's the big challenge but
but i do wonder if
if we can get rid of you know the
millionaires and billionaires who are
influencing politics negatively and
subverting the will of the working-class
individuals in this country
let's make a list a list of the uh the
millionaires and the billionaires
i just love saying let's make a list
like all those canceled people do let's
make a list of these
people and you know who it is
everyone knows who's influencing
politics the
rich people yup just make it stop
he trump was probably the closest you
were going to get to that his notion of
draining the swamp but then you saw how
deep the swamp goes
back years and years some rich guy that
comes in that's
uh you know a tv star isn't going to
shift that thing they hated him
so much trump's biggest problem i think
was that he didn't
drain the swamp yeah he said he was
going to and the twitter stuff
he could have been so much better if he
just kept his tweets to himself
it would have been way better 50 50.
okay some some of the tweets
circumvented media lies and a lot of
times
hilarious too oh man you know my
favorite tweet is
okay because the people who watch know
this was when elizabeth warren was doing
that really awful live stream
do you remember that yeah and she was
like i'm gonna get me a beer
yeah and then she like goes and get a
beer her husband walks up
and he like smacks around the ass and
she's like and i'm like
wow that was like a really bad moment
for a presidential campaign
yeah but sure fine i guess it's the
husband and wife but she goes i'm glad
you're here
trump tweeted she said elizabeth
warren's husband comes in he says i'm
glad you're here he's supposed to be
there he lives there
it was it's such an amazing tweet
because it was like
something you'd hear uh you're at your
friend's place and his dad's in there
and it was just it wasn't about politics
it wasn't about policy
or you know party or anything he was
just pointing out an absurdity and it
was really funny
he was so funny shane gillis had this
joke when shane got fired
he came back right away and jumped right
into the stuff
shane gillis if you don't know is a
brilliant comic
and you see he saturday night live would
have helped him
inevitably but he's going to make it no
matter what shane had this joke where he
just goes you know people complain about
and he goes
i didn't vote for trump but
for those that are listening yeah aaron
winked i winked very
at him very succinctly and he goes but
he's hilario he's funnier than 95
of the comedian he goes he goes if he
came on after me he would bury me he'd
be like
look at that gay not funny fat
he was fired and it was right after the
snl firing and it was just such a great
topical joke
i got invited to the white house and uh
the sub shop in atlantic city
yes yeah no no i i got invited to the
white house it was the it was the
the white house social media summit okay
and i was like
finally you know in 2018 i said
republicans were too stupid the
politicians too stupid to deal with
social media censorship to save their
own
you know positions and i was right i
like that you brought that up as a
subject and then said positions instead
of the word you wanted to say but uh
well i'm like wait wait no i mean like i
thought you were their jobs
okay they got it or their lives whatever
but to save their own jobs they didn't
realize they were getting crushed with
social media censorship their supporters
and fans were being
ripped away and so i said that in 2018
surprisingly
you know i actually thought republicans
were still going to win and they lost
and i was like well there you go i guess
i
got half of it right so i get invited to
this white house summit
i'm all excited like finally the
republicans are going to do something
about this
and do you know what i got to experience
instead of a serious and legitimate
conversation about social media
censorship a little cocktail party where
they want everybody
to be nice and donald trump doing an
hour of stand up
come on legit come on it was hilarious
i want to hit the table oh great it was
hilarious just him it was so it was did
he have an opener
i think he did who was but it was a
really boring like
i think he had an opener i just don't
remember because it didn't matter
because trump
basically did stand up i'm telling you
trump did stand up trump does stand up
his rallies
are almost stand up yes this crowd work
he'll do a bit
then he'll walk away from the mic which
is a weird thing that's
that's a very urban comic thing to do
the room
was like i was a couple hundred of
trump's most ardent supporters
oh i wish i could i was the only one not
wearing a suit i'm wearing this
and people are laughing like tim pool
shows up everyone's in a suit but him
and i was like because i'm here for yeah
like look i'm not going to wear a suit
it's not what i'm here for
serious matter and we need to get
something happening well i'm like listen
listen
look at this guy with his toucan yeah so
in that's a canadian word by the way
duke is a very canadian
no no but i'm like in america people ask
me about i'm like in america
you can be some regular dude going to
the white house and speaking your mind
you know god you don't got to be
somebody who owns a suit right that's
why i like this country i can show up in
the white house wearing my normal
clothes
and that's what america is about i don't
got to put on my formal dress to tire my
wards my pins or anything i can be an
american saying listen up this matters
now there was some serious nature to it
but i got to tell you man i sat there
and at first i was kind of getting let
down by what was going on
and then i just started just rolling
with it i'm like this guy's hilarious
yeah he jokes about himself being orange
yeah he's like the lights
it's not my fault they call me orange
but they put on the d everyone's
laughing
they get it yeah they're they're
self-aware and it's funny how
you know when the left tries to make fun
of trump they use the exact same state
jokes he's overweight orange and his
small hands and i'm like
dude trump's already used that bit in
stand up you can't just keep saying it
the joke's done yeah these people are
stealing trump's bit it was all they had
he was great with crowd i mean he wasn't
great there's a handful of comics that
are great i
i mean i believe i'm i'm one of the best
crowd work comics around big jokerson
david tell there's a few but he was
fun for his level of experience he did
look at this gay he's ugly
what's he doing here and when he does
that yell thing like
the fake news yeah you see this woman
fat woman i tell you she has no idea
what she's and he does things like it's
a very
borst battle style of guy i tell you
take my wife
please it's like he's had this rodney
dangerfield kind of asteroid
because he his favorite comic and he
will disavow this now
was jeff ross he loved ross and ross
loved playing with him and then as soon
as he got in ross was like
yeah and i love jeff ross but he had his
moment where he's like i got it do you
remember
in in the 2016 cycle when megan kelly
was like
you've called women yeah pigs he goes
only
rosie o'donnell and the crowd erupts
yeah and it was like
they did and it was at a time when she's
attacking him and you
think that they're gonna jump on it he
turns it into a joke she's bleeding from
everywhere
i don't know the phone call that was a
phone call from her eyes or you know
whatever
he just like outside of that stuff trump
needed to get his switch under control
but i think
if you're somebody who is just
tribalistic
i think there's a lot of people who are
scared didn't want to fall out of line
with the tribe
they're worried about being ostracized
or shunned or fired or whatever so they
just say oh yeah i hate trump too
then there are a lot of people who are
just blind zealots who are like trump is
bad
but the people who are interested in
actually listening what he had to say we
hear so many stories with people walking
away from the democratic party
when they finally decided to just watch
a trump video
because they learned that the media was
lying
and they also laughed and they were like
that's not what they were like the media
was saying he said this that
then i watched the speech and it was
actually just like him cracking jokes
and like
yeah he didn't say those things sure
they took a lot of stuff out of context
people
basically everything didn't like him and
there was also
a group of people that really liked him
because so many people hated him and
then you looked at the people that hated
them
and you're like oh these people are
really surfaces
my wife really weird my wife was like
here's the problem with democracy she
attacks it from a political standpoint
and and
structures good arguments so you can
listen to them but other people are just
like
he's a racist bigot xenophobic caused
all this and you're like oh these people
are idiots
maybe i'm going to listen more to what
he's saying right than these people
and that's what what most of it was when
when you
when you looked to the prominent
progressive and liberal personalities in
the country they couldn't offer up a
compelling argument against trump
yeah and so you got people who are
sitting back in their chairs laughing
at what they found to be a a comedy
central style roast
of the political establishment you know
trump was just
going at the political establishment
making fun of them attacking them
insulting them
and for so many americans it felt good
was it michael moore i think called
trump a human molotov
cocktail and he said to all of these
people what trump is saying it's like
music to their ears
and on november 9th 2016 they're going
to the voting booth
and they're going to send the biggest fu
to the political establishment
ever in the history of humanity and he
was right he got the next part wrong
he goes and they'll be happy for a week
maybe a month and then they'll realize
like the people who voted for brexit
when in actuality people were extremely
happy for quite some time
do you know how good your michael moore
impression is i can do great impressions
man
i can shut my eyes do more go do more oh
i can't do it now it's so good come on
just stop your inner sensor and just do
it
no no there's no
why do you feel like i'm like dance
monkey no no i'm not i'm not such a good
i'm not actually good enough the best
michael moore i've ever heard i'm not
good enough to
do impressions on cue i can flow into it
in a conversation and then invoke like
what i remember of them
if i practiced i could probably all
right practice because it's really a
skill that you might
excel at yeah impersonations yeah uh he
was right man people
like they watched trump and it just felt
good he was throwing he was a human
molotov cocktail being thrown into the
system and he made people laugh
the pacing of the michael moore
impression is perfect
yeah it's just i'm not gonna put you on
the spot but i think like for
for your content afterwards i think it
should just be you as
michael moore i should i should do more
so good voiceover for uh freedom tunes
yes
it's good practice yeah yeah yeah but
anyway you know we got into the subject
of trump and it's kind of like a a
post-mortem i guess in the trump
presidency and where we're at these days
joe biden is stumbling downstairs he's
uh giving
kamala harris all of the jobs she's
calling foreign leaders she's dealing
with the border crisis
i said this i said joe biden he's going
to win
they're going to put him in his
wheelchair they're going to put the
little blanket on his lap and they're
going to wheel him into the sun room and
he's going to
and then annie's going to come in and
daddy warbucks will be there too
biden's going to be sleeping in the sun
in the study and kamala harris is going
to be
like let's get to work yeah and that's
basically what we're getting
he tries to run up the stair stairs to
make it seem like he's look man
joe doesn't need to convince anybody
that he's he's he's young
because he's not he's almost 80 years
old bro just walk up the stairs
he tries to like walk upstairs and he
falls three times right
he tried to like you know sort of rustle
up the stairs i don't want to say run
but like move
more quickly like jog hustle hustle yeah
it's tough to do on that plane yeah and
then he falls over
and then they said it was windy he's
falling up was the wind you know
you know when the wind knocks you off
the stairs right yeah when you when
you're right in florida in the midst of
a tornado just standing outside trying
to sleep with your cousin
you know what actually i wonder if
someone if there's someone who's good
enough at vfx they could add a tornado
background to that video
and show the wind and like chairs chairs
flying and maybe a cow or two
i read today that i did not know this
and maybe you can shed some wisdom on
this kamala harris does not need to
salute
anybody i saw that as the vice president
is that normal or what i don't know i
don't know if it's
it must be because of that office
because she's not military
is that why it is i don't think she's in
any kind of command i don't think he's
part of the military
he has to right biden has to i don't i
don't know if he has
no he's a commander he doesn't have to
yeah it's like respect i guess
it seems like they get no respect yeah i
don't know i think kamala harris is
is the is the acting president and when
you wait look
there's reports that she's the one
talking to world leaders she's now in
charge of the border crisis what is
biden doing
he's complaining about guns on tv i
guess yeah
he shows up i i i love seeing
the trouble at the border and just
knowing that it wasn't the last
president's fault only
and just their fault these are these are
bigger places and they're more
comfortable to keep these migrant
children that we've separated from their
families
the whole the whole just own up to it if
they just owned up to it
wouldn't you and wouldn't other people
go hey now we can listen to what they
want to say like wouldn't it level the
playing field for you
as we were talking about with black
panther and if we had a you know black
president
what they could get away with they
weaponized their
own problems against trump barack obama
created these facilities
trump inherited them and then they
blamed trump while posting photos from
the obama administration
then trump shut them down this is crazy
trump shut down some of these facilities
biden reopened them yeah apparently
kamala harris was protesting out in
front of one of them
and then reopened it yeah it's amazing
how that works right
and uh what do we get now there's like
this really cringe video of a woman
singing part of your world by the little
mermaid song
but it's about joe biden i watched
literally two seconds and i was like i
can't watch
your head exploded and you just fell
over and i was just like i'm not gonna
i'm not giving this two minutes
yeah i didn't even have time to take a
nap today and i was all excited to get
here and i'm like i don't have the two
minutes
to be fair well actually no i was gonna
say to be fair the wright does have
their meme videos of trump but i gotta
be honest the meme videos of trump were
actually funny
like you ever see the one where i think
it was carpe dongdum where it's the time
magazine cover
and it says trump 2024 trump 2028 trump
35 30. and it keeps going
and then it shows trump dancing and the
number keeps going and they all freaked
out it was hilarious
it was the one where trump's doing that
weird dance where he does the weird fist
thing
white guy dancing and it's like playing
that song or whatever those were funny
the memes were funny they were
ridiculous but the meme like the things
they're doing now
the democrats about biden it's like i
liken it to this
you ever see uh uh like pure flicks or
like old
really low quality christian versions of
superheroes and stuff bible man and
veggie tales and stuff
i think so that that's basically what
the
the left has become hollywood and the tv
industry the democrats
are this like low quality unhip
facsimile
of actual fun mainstream culture
the puritans have taken it over and now
they're producing just cringe ideology
content yeah
the message is more important than the
the content but
that being said people seek out
genuine thought and genuine
entertainment more so than they used to
people are more aware of their choices
right yeah yeah yeah
and it's a lot of reruns a lot of older
movies newer movies man i tell you
it's shockingly bad stuff i had we have
an artist named
matt miller he does all of our artwork
like these wuhan shirts and stuff and
i'm not trying to plug them but i'm just
telling you how innovative he is
he worked on this movie that was about
these stuntmen
that did a jump and on their car
was a confederate flag because it was
modeled after the dukes of hazard thing
the movie's gone they pulled the movie
from everyone because they're
confederate because there's a
confederate flag
on a car in a movie can i maybe i should
just fund a short film or
maybe like a feature length just a
really low budget but like a well
lo well done low budget that just is
like
the anti-locust of anti-woke i i think
we should
first of all i'll do it with you but
lose the idea of very low budget and at
least go to medium budget but what's
medium budget because i'm i mean like
low budget is 150k
we could make that's what i mean
absolutely
low budget could be like now you could
shoot a movie on a phone it'd be crappy
but
150k we make like an 80s style
totally ranch pc movie
uh my buddy zach nguyen had this idea
too can it be like a buddy cop film
it could be whatever you want give me
150k i got the people we'll put it
together let's make a move
man let's do it script come on you're
antiquated
i mean i had the money we were right
before coveted we were going to do a
cancel culture movie
and we were going to cozy up to the guys
that were canceling online
and pretend that we weren't going to do
a bad thing and then we're going to
cover
shane gillis and cover all these people
and then hopefully find
you know all these canceled people have
horrible skeletons of their closet i
don't know if you know what drives them
yeah but they're yelling loudly to cover
up what they're hiding
were you gonna you're gonna do like a
fictional movie no
we're gonna do a doc because i did a doc
called 25 sets where i did 25 shows
in a night 25 stand-up shows and night
and then uh
james altucher who uh owns stand-up new
york was like let's do something else
and we came up with this
we've been trying to get him to come on
the show too but it's like james is
great i'll talk to him
yeah trying to i mean we should need to
find a schedule for all this yeah he's
in florida now because
he said new york is dead yeah and then
he got out of there
and i love james and then you remember
seinfeld was like no it's okay i can see
it from the hamptons
yes uh
that's trump doing seinfeld yeah
see i'm not as good at impressions as
you i really just want to hear there's
only there's only some that i'm really
good at
yeah but um i guess a decent amount yeah
yeah
it's a great skill to have uh but yeah
we should we should definitely
do an over the top on pc
80 style ranch fat remember porkies
where they're like looking through the
hole and the girls are changing
i don't know that one porky's was a
classic and it was shot in canada too
that was like yeah that was one of the
remember it was movies where you're like
oh
tits and you were so excited i was just
born
in the late 80s or yeah i was born in 86
sorry i was born in 72.
so you got to grow up with all that
craziness hot dog
these are movies you i i will watch
black panther
if you watch hot dog and porkies fair
deal
all right hot dog was great it's a ski
movie and there's like a stereotypical
asian guy he's like
he's so scared to ski and then that's
how he talked i'm doing an impression
and then uh but you just seem like oh
boobs like hot tub scenes and you're so
excited for boobs yeah
i i've seen with fast times that was the
80s right yeah
fast times is pretty good great
soundtrack let's do it let's let's let's
make a
stereotypical 80s anti-woke all right we
get uh
maybe we even get ryan long involved
definitely yeah yeah he's
he's we're we're working together on the
hour pillow project and
we'll see if we can we can get it
together and we'll see how it plays out
because i don't know if the the pillow
thing is actually going to end up
happening
for like you know the good pillow yeah i
think the news cycle kind of has
rants course but we have that burlap
sack over there yeah i see it full of
packing peanuts it's very funny
so we're uh you know we're thinking
about it it's
super topical so it only really works if
david hogg actually does start a pillow
company yeah and i'm not sure he's
actually gonna do it
but if he does then we're gonna have the
communist version of my pillow
that's great yeah do you feel
uh when you look at a school shooting
like
that one uh that grabs so much notoriety
for so long
i go down to florida twice a year we got
like a little condo there and i go down
and do comedy a lot
my wife came with me and she did a
parkland joke
10 minutes outside of parkland and the
whole crowd turned on her it's all like
they were mad they were offended i think
is the best way to put it
uh and she's like what's the problem
whenever she opens for me she inevitably
walks some of the crowd or just defends
them and doesn't understand why i don't
want her to open for me
uh so her name's christine mienberg by
the way she's very funny
and i'm just wondering do you think in
the cases of these school shootings
where a school shooting happens is that
neighborhood
then safe for 30 years after would you
send a kid
to that school if you go hey i'm going
to move down to parkland now because i
think it's out of the way
definitely not you you think i think
they're going to overreact and create
overbearing laws and panic
and it's going to become nightmarish for
the people who live there
you look at like norway for instance and
there was a
tragic event we'll call it it and they
mourned and they carried on
because they realized that we can't
control the wind
you know what i mean yeah in the u.s you
get chicago
every weekend every weekend for decades
and they laugh in your face
and insult you when you bring it up they
say you don't really
like it it's remarkable to me that i'm
like hey i'm kind of from this place
and i actually interviewed a black woman
who was leading the charge on
protecting gun rights getting illegal
guns off the street
and advocating for victims of gun
violence they don't care
they don't want to talk about it and
they will tell you to shut your mouth
when you do
but then when you get some you know
these other tragic events that
negatively impact or scare the white
progressive wealthy and affluent suburbs
all of a sudden now they demand you bend
the knee but what happens is they panic
and they create overbearing and insane
rules laws and regulations that don't
make sense
literally don't why do people not care
about black communities poor black
community
it's tribalism that guides everything
the democratic tribe
and i'm not talking about leftists like
socialists who actually want
socialism and they want marxist
revolution or whatever the democrat
tribe doesn't care about
any kind of principle i learned this at
very early early at a young age
when all the democrats were protesting
george w bush and war the moment obama
got elected
they were gone and they were singing and
dancing about obama while he bombed kids
and i was like wow those people lied
about it and bomb flint bomb flint
yeah what do you mean this was in a
michael moore movie you would know
11 9 or whatever yeah so was there any
truth to that
or am i just way off base and that's a
conspiracy
but michael moore is genuinely nuts he
thinks donald trump got elected because
of gwen stefani yeah and his doc
i'm not kidding he says gwen stefani got
paid more money and trump got mad
so he used a presidential campaign run
to boost his salary
so that he could go to nbc and claim now
that he's a president
presidential candidate they should pay
him more wow the reason that's psychotic
is that donald trump registered make
america great again
years like i think four or five years
before he even actually announced his
run yeah
everybody knew he was preparing to run
and he even talked about running back i
think 2000 for the reform party or
something
so michael moore has just gone totally
crackpot yeah but
the example because i've been talking
about gun control a lot they come out
and they're like
because of these events we got to ban
the ar-15 and it's like bro that's just
like saying
ban gun it doesn't mean anything bana
air 15
what ar-15 what caliber what kind of
what are you talking about when you say
that because there's a bunch of other
semi-automatic rifles that are
functionally the same
that aren't ar-15s so basically they're
coming out and they're telling you to
ban something that won't change
anything they're complaining about it is
just an overbearing
like reaction to a crisis so to your
question
i would not send my kid or move to these
neighborhoods they're going to have laws
like
you can if the cat sneezes it's a 20
fine and you're gonna be like what
you're gonna be like it's the law
and because they panic that's the knee
jerk reaction is to
make people more afraid well we gotta go
to super chats we are
we're going a little bit a little longer
than this but it was fun so for those
that are listening if you haven't
already
smash the like button hit that
notification bell subscribe to the show
go to timcast.com become a member
because we're going to have an exclusive
members only segment probably going to
be one of the dirtiest comedy bits we've
heard in a long time i guess
that's how you're making it sound but uh
it's i mean it's
pretty safe for what i do but yeah it'll
be it'll be fun and i'm sure it'll be
profanity-laced so
but uh but again we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna we are going to read your
super chats
so smash that like button let's jump
right in
graf von tirl says reddit hired someone
who enabled
pedos and banned people from bringing
that person up to me that's the last
straw i've deleted my reddit account
over this
and i remember all kinds of poor
decisions prior to this that
is a huge scandal right now i saw that
yeah read it hiring this person and then
trying to cover it up
it's freaking people out jay smith says
uh
have aaron berg ask you if you like john
cougar mellencamp
who's oh boy that's a musician right uh
yeah
it's uh it's a bit that we do on our
show you remember
we'll save this for after but uh you're
you're whatever song did he do
remember uh the sucking on a chili dog
thing
so now it's gone little ditty about jack
and diane
two american kids oh yeah yeah yeah
so then one guy did this thing where he
goes suck it on the chili dog suck it so
he made the whole song
just the word sucking on a chili dog uh
and what we do is i lure people in and i
go hey do you like john cougar
mellencamp and you go oh yeah and i go
which song do you love and you go that
one
so then we start to play that song and
then we show scat porn to it
uh
[Laughter]
says how long until mlk is canceled and
the statues are torn down
he was a conservative republican
preacher who had misogynistic tendencies
tim do you think you'd ever go on what
is that tism
what is that i have no idea i don't know
what that is no no um it's very soon
that he's going to get cancelled
i'm okay yeah definitely come on bro
do you believe in dr king's dream
that well i do i don't know that one day
my four little children will be judged
not by the color of their skin but by
the contemporary character sure that'd
be great to me
okay that that defies so you're saying
we should judge him by the content of
his character
martin luther king yeah we should
definitely judge him by the content of
his character but it's
do as i say not as i do don't you woke
don't like martin luther king jr really
they might lie
and claim it because regular liberals
will be shocked
if you take ibram x candy this famous
worker robin d'angelo
and they went to a seminar with a bunch
of run-of-the-mill liberal types and
said
they think that the king that dr king
was wrong the liberals would go whoa
whoa
that's an affront to their world view so
they have to
feign support for a colorblind future
while advocating for a
you know color vision whatever yeah like
a racially segregated future wouldn't it
be easier to just be honest
and go well no they want power they
believe they have the right to lie to
steal it
geez yeah so that's why i ask liberals
who are
indoctrinated i'll say do you agree with
dr king's dream when they say yes
and like i specify his dream was
specifically the kind of character then
i say
how does what you are doing with racial
segregation at colleges support dr
king's dream
and they get really angry yeah because
they're fighting against
martin luther king jr yeah they are
fighting his vision and his dream
i heard these stories from my
grandparents man i knew all about civil
rights and i can tell you these people
absolutely were the bad guys back then
the bad guys today
the problem is today they've regained
power and they're starting to win
these are right-wing reactionaries the
corporate democrats are not
authoritarian left they're not they
pretend to be maybe but they're
authoritarian
probably centrist or authoritarian right
for the most part they don't care about
whether it's a corporation or a
communism
they care about command they care about
corporatism
so they can claim to be somewhat
traditional or somewhat progressive
but still just want to seize your rights
seize your guns take away your speech
these are and they want to rewind the
clock to bring us back to an era of
racial segregation
and animosity and it's working they're
doing it they're creating these racial
affinity groups they're segregating
people based on race at universities
and they're exacerbating and flaming
racial tensions in this country
they're doing it on purpose under the
guise of opposing racism
doing everything in their power to make
more people racist
so we're right in what regard in every
regard
of all the points that i've brought up
these people that are crying racism
are the ones that are racist themselves
right not necessarily so
a lot of these people are blind zealots
that's why okay so
they're tribal and they're jumping onto
that bandwagon because they think it's
the right
and they're being led by the democratic
party which is the party historically of
jim crow segregation racism slavery this
this the
the confederates we all know that but
people then look at that and go well no
they've changed this party
that was a very clever strategy on the
part of democrats they knew they
knew you're not going to win so let me
ask you this i'm a good person
agree from what you know so far so far
so good yeah there you go
okay good that's all i needed to hear
that that's what the battle is for
by people that are constantly under
attack because we're made to believe
that we're
horrible people for saying the things we
say or doing the things we do which
include
taking care of our families supporting
people making people laugh
uh starting positive communities wanting
to give back to communities how many
people
committed to hate crime against an asian
because of dave chappelle's joke where
he mocked chinese people
none none no i i guarantee you
and i would be willing i would and i try
to avoid absolutes
but i am willing to bet a substantial
amount of money that not a single person
watched dave chappelle make fun of
chinese people
and then got instantly filled with a
blinding rage and then wanted to commit
hate crime yeah
but what did jay leno say what does
other comics say
ellery smith this robot chicken writer
says that her joke about pod thai
contributed to the violence no it didn't
shut up you egotist
yeah you think you're so important so
special and so influential you are not
you're some random teenagers have
something dumb on the internet no one
cares no one cares
that's what the the lies they push and
it's obvious when they don't criticize
dave chappelle for it
i can't it would offend delicate
sensibilities of uninitiated liberals
i did a show years ago called white guys
matter
and it was just white stand-up comics
and it was
satirical you laughed at it because you
understand you're making
a show yes we matter we need jobs we
matter
and we went i did it in toronto on a
night
hear nothing about it it's a wednesday i
talked to mark breslin who
owns yucky and i go hey for the
wednesday you want to do the show
white guys matter because wednesday's
normally 20 30 people this is back when
i wouldn't draw that much he goes all
right it's not going to help ticket sale
sure enough two days before people catch
wind of it
they're so upset boom show sells out
people attacking he's a nazi he's a
right-wing
my grandmother was in the holocaust
that's but you know that's
that's just an argument you would use
against nazism uh
and then uh of course without telling
anybody i donate all the proceeds to a
black trans charity
without telling anybody yeah but then if
someone finds out
well he did that to cover up the no it's
just
funny and good so why are they so
judgmental
when when we're not we aren't judging
them
saying they're bullies they want power
they'll lie to get it
there you go no no but we're the bullies
in their eyes and that's how they make
everything seem well i'll tell you this
there are some people who are bullies
for sure
and that's the weapons the weapon
they're looking for that's why i i was
critical of tucker carlson when he
ragged on taylor lorenz
i'm like dude you want to criticize the
tweet of a journalist you can
not mention their name yeah explain a
new york times journalist
said this leave their name out they'll
still try and feign some kind of
victimhood
they need that they need conservatives
to do this and for some reason
conservatives think they're fighting an
equal on an equal footing that's
not no they're fighting an uphill battle
yeah the rules don't apply to the left
the same way they do the right so the
right
when they engage in name calling and
calling people out the way the left in
the media does
it doesn't work it's worse you're giving
the ammo they're asking for they're
cheering and laughing at you when you do
it
i don't i don't name my enemies ever
right yeah you talk about the things
they say the ideas or the institutions
that's right
sometimes i'll name some people if
they're in a powerful enough position
politicians i'll name all the time
because it's civics all right here we
got uh the black blade says
weird i'm 39 and officially retired have
some ex rollerblader love and get some
new coping
bolt a new rail to the ground add some
vert to the half pipe and as always keep
up the magnificent work
it will do artificia artifices
says what do you think about the idea
that creators add to attention
commodification via
donors subs also perpetuating the idea
that it is impossible to do what you do
due to market saturation
what makes your opinion more valuable
than anyone else's with similar
experience
i don't know i can talk really fast for
a really long time and i make a ton of
content
that's it probably it uh
there's a lot of people i've watched
their content and they can't talk as
quickly
and for as long i'm not even kidding
i know but it's funny to me that it's so
simplistic
yet it seems so difficult
i talk fast i talk fast and i can talk
forever
i learned it because i used to do
fundraising for non-profits yeah there's
a trick there's a couple different sales
techniques
one of them is the slow hypnotic sales
pitch
where you don't let them leave and you
talk
really slow so when you have and then
they're just eventually like ah
but then there's also the ultra fast i'm
telling you this is the most important
thing in the world you're going to get
your credit card right now we're going
to sign this form because you are going
to be changing the world you want to
change the world right of course you do
you already said yes i know you love it
martin luther king rape me
all right ben all right that's too much
but yeah so it's you know i i used to do
fundraising and it was
talk really fast from my my pitch was
usually
the big bang boom you know here we're
going to go and you you make them go
like whoa whoa whoa and then like
definitely and then they sign up and
you mix up sometimes the slow talk and
the fast talk that would be great you
could hit the head with a rock or like
an air conditioner falls down and bangs
you on the head and you're like
so as i was saying
then they feel bad and they donate yeah
all right christopher noll says shout
out to ds wilson in his new book atlas
hugged
ebook for as little as one dollar you
left libs will love his criticism of ein
rand
must read could be ian's presidential
playbook defund the fed
very good hey interesting cap uh let's
see cpl hillbilly that corporal
hillbilly says north korea launched two
icbms into the sea of japan today yahoo
news told me so
that's freaky jim satala says hey aaron
jim from florida here
are you saying that
[Laughter]
read it are you saying that two wongs
make a white
ihw rules compound media is the free
speech network
i'm allowed to say that because i am
part asian that's right
everybody has to know if dave chappelle
can make fun of asians i can
playfully join in and make fun of my own
family and
he's part asian too i bet yeah yeah sure
i'm sorry
enough i suppose is that everything well
i think
i'm allowed to there's actually a really
funny college humor bit
where there's a panel of a full asian a
half asian and a quarter asian
and they're judging mixed race asian
people and giving them permission to do
certain things
yeah it's a really funny bit so like a
guy walks in he goes i'm 1 16 asian on
my mom's side
when i'm or when i'm eating a chinese
chinese restaurant can i order with an
accent and use chopsticks
and they're like yeah we think that
one's okay
you're good and then at the end they're
like the the uh
are you really black panel a guy a white
guy walks in and he goes my great great
grandfather was black and they go you're
black
that was the joke from college humor i
guess i love it like the asians were
arguing about it
yeah brandon savage says tim five bucks
says you can get shane gillis on your
show yeah
a case of beer might lock in the deal
yeah i'd love to have them that'd be
great
garrett norman says tim did you see the
forbes article about the biden
administration asking the supreme court
to ignore the second and fourth
amendment
written by nick sabella i did see that
it's amazing that's where we're at
these days huh brandon freeman says tim
ian lydia what did you guys do to luke
have you poured any new concrete slabs
lately i'd like some professionals to
come and inspect your casa with some
luminol
love the show luke uh he abandoned us
we didn't do anything to it yeah this is
we basically voluntarily we bagged we
were like luke don't leave and he was
like i've had enough
i can't do it anymore he said that the
pressure was just too great
and that he was scared of of greatness
he was here his only choice was to run
to the beaches of florida and hide
because he realized that if he if he did
stay on the show too long
that people would uh hold he he would
have a certain responsibility
you know with great power comes great
responsibility and he doesn't yeah he
doesn't want to be too famous and he
doesn't want to be
uh uh he just couldn't do it yeah he was
he was just too scared
yeah the strain was too much for him to
bear
all right jonathan i hope he's listening
by the way jonathan trembley says i work
for waltons
we sell uh meat processing equipment and
supplies
we created meat gistics to teach people
to make awesome
is it messed products because it's using
mess okay meat products well it says
mask twice
oh interesting meat products if you get
into hunting
snid uh and want to learn all right
and want to learn how to make awesome
sausage and jerky i'd love to teach you
and supply the needed equipment very
cool i don't know if i can get into that
maybe uh other people
ben walker says speaking of good comics
what are the odds we can get tim dillon
and his producer ben on here always
hilarious but he's really been killing
the game lately
i think the issue with people like tim
dillon is that these comics that are
gaining
anybody who's gaining too big of an
audience too quickly has no reason to
come on a show
if they already have their own platform
so some people will some people won't
people get busy too we got one for you
all right
rook says aaron berg looks like great
value joe rogan
that's true i get that often great value
is a good one great value
yeah it's better than discount right
right right i like that because you know
you go to
great values what's walmart's brand yeah
great value
it's almost you're a better value joe
rogan thank you
smirking fidel says jay leno was
literally the ambassador for political
correctness
he's not short he's vertically
challenged remember that line of comedy
on the tonight show he ushered in the
wokeness
really wow well jay leno is another one
of these
late nights you know talk show hosts
undead neanderthal says hey tim and crew
love the show can i get a shout out from
my podcast
land of the shadow people host by the
paranormal pilgrim i like it well there
you go check that out guys
bethany l says would you guys consider
discussing the breaking story about the
reddit
mod um perhaps i don't know too much
about it this is the mod that apparently
is associated with like the liberal
democrats in the uk
okay yeah and they were trying to cover
up that they were involved in some
really creepy goings-on but so i guess
they made a bot to just scrub her name
from all the posts which was super
interesting
read it as a corporation did yeah wow i
think so yeah it's a little sketchy
el furious strout says tim you've
inspired me to start creating music yes
i've recorded some concept vocals to a
new song i'm writing called power grab
it's on my channel now i look forward to
the feedback thanks for all that you do
irl crew thank you very much
very cool brandon tom says
look at look at tim denigrating trump's
masculinity based on outward traits
alone
as if we don't revere little engines
that could david's and goliaths
what about the masculine traits of
always fighting for what's right and
overcoming impossible odds well i think
we'd eventually get to the
the mentality of masculinity too yeah we
did
so all right jack herrera says let's
talk about the ufos or the border crisis
maybe we'll get into that in the uh
exclusive members only segment so uh
again make sure you're over at
timcast.com as a member and you're
smashing that like button
miss swaggerwagon says as soon as your
app is out i'm canceling my
ytp and joining also today is my monday
and
and i listen at work so i've binged
three episodes three episodes today keep
on being dope thanks to everyone
i appreciate it so we the new website is
coming soon
we're trying to make sure we roll it out
perfectly so that no members are
affected
affected negatively and then we're going
to have an app coming out shortly after
that
we still are going to have everything on
youtube so you know just so you know
keyblade master andy says it seems
there's a lot of people in the chat that
doubt you were ever homeless care to
elaborate
um okay i was
18 and left my house because i was 18
and i went to go work at o'hare for
american eagle airlines
and i'd lived with my grandpa for a
little bit i had
oh man long story so my dad had an
apartment he had already pre-paid the
lease he moved out
so when i was 18 i moved into that
studio with my brother and me and my
friends hung out with at least expired
eventually
i then had nowhere to go so my parents
were like well you can live with your
grandpa
live with my grandpa for a little bit
started working for this is when i was
working at o'hare
airport and then some family things
happen my grandpa passed away
and then i had nowhere to go in order to
get to the airport
i had to live close enough to the
airport because i
had to be there by 5 a.m because my
shift started at 5 30
and then couldn't live with my family
they wouldn't let me so i started
sleeping in the airport i had a car
started sleeping in a car
and then there was a period where my car
had you know
stripped tires at long story short there
were a few nights i ended up sleeping
outside
slept in my car for the most part over
the period of a few months slept at the
airport for a little bit
and then uh eventually just got sick of
it ended up quitting
and then moving and it's actually i
think it's fair to say that
i was hard homeless on and off for a
short period and then i was sleeping on
friend's couches homeless for an
extended period
that's the easiest way to describe it i
suppose would you sleep in the front
seat
uh yeah usually and i got a ticket once
i had
i had left work and was like super tight
so i worked a double shift
and so i pulled off on the side of the
road in the middle of nowhere and was
like i got to go to sleep
i'm going to sleep here and a cop woke
me up and gave me a parking ticket and i
was like i'm sitting here with the
blinkers
i don't care and i was like great the
poor get poorer because i can't afford
to pay this yeah
and then you know a bunch of other stuff
happened my license got suspended and
man talk about
so bouncing around from different
friends who would have me
and uh yeah that's all eventually good
times
ended up how did i end up finding it oh
yeah eventually one of my friends let me
crash in their pantry which was big
for a couple hundred bucks then from
there
i actually ended up getting my own place
and then i had this like three bedroom
apartment with like seven people living
in it so nobody paid anything that
skateboarders do
yeah and then i moved to los angeles got
a job made some money finally got a real
apartment and i worked my way up from
there i used to wash my hands with
rainwater
i was living in my buddy's car wow
glamorous david murdock says hey tim you
talk video games and zombies
real life drag queen zane uh dimagge is
zombie slayer extraordinaire battling
mobs
suffering a mind virus in drag the dead
third person shooter now in development
counterculture learn more at david
murdock art on twitter and mines
cool jordan says trump may not be the
most masculine but it's hard to argue
that he isn't an alpha he walks into a
room and everyone instantly gravitates
towards him
and he tends to control the situation
that is 100 percent true
he is a dominating and imposing figure
that people cannot give up so i don't
know if you call it masculinity
people are addicted to donald trump
period they loved him on tv they loved
him for who he was
that when he was president no one could
shut up about him
everyone i'm gonna say this
i think he exited with grace on that
final day
i was thinking that too yeah where he's
just like you're all special people
i love you and then he didn't do the
football handoff whenever he just got in
a plane and flew to florida yeah
and then there was some democrat guy who
was like it's you know he did a
hypothetical he's like
1201 pm donald trump lands in florida
black suvs are racing down the tarmac
lights flashing
they surround the plane men in black
suits jump out guns drawn
donald trump is finally being arrested
and i'm like just these people it's blue
and on man these people are crazy
they don't go to jail these people all
right cereal says just came back after a
30 minute break
had to take time to talk to a friend
about purchasing a handgun because i'm
nervous biden will make it impossible
soon
also rising tensions have have me
worried many thanks pool crew
um 3d printed run 3d printed guns are
here to stay
i mean it's just there's nothing that's
going to be can be done about it
ashley and ks says i love compound media
week on irl chrissy then berg
erin how soon till you ditch gino and
join kumia
uh today i came on this show to make the
announcement i am firing gino biscuit
and i'm curious
i will not believe that no i have to
gino and i will be together uh
i have to i'm gonna have to issue an
apology after realizing the super chat
they say
uh wong tan says tim aaron is a racist
who co-hosts a show with racist gino
descante and racist compound media also
owned by a racist vampire
we're gonna have to issue an apology
over your appearance it's uh it's quite
acceptable
i would like to apologize to everybody
hey really helping it there jt says
people who fear
black guns and want them banned are just
lashing out because of their
internalized white supremacy
i love you ian stay amazing thank you
all right jason van kirk says tim there
are 614 billionaires in the u.s and 18.7
millionaires love the show everyone keep
with the good work
and we should tax all of their money
everything i'm kidding
um but the how about we all agree that
the hollywood and media ones those
those are that's fair game right yeah
their money i'm with you on it
conservatives and and progressives alike
we agree
yeah that's the compromise yes we can't
tax all of the rich
but we can tax the rich that the
conservatives don't like yeah well i
don't think the
the leftists like these people either
they don't like liberals
softshell crab says what do you all
think about overtime being taxed should
it continue to be taxed or not no
why not because i worked with nurses and
they would work extra hours and they
would be like it doesn't matter how much
i work i'm just going to be moved up
like a tax not a tax bracket you were
telling me that but it wasn't going to
increase their pay enough that they were
never going to see a single penny
how much they were well think about it
this way if you uh
overtime is usually what time and a half
yeah so that that will offset any
increase in your tax bracket if you go
to a higher level
but interestingly if you are making you
know eighty thousand a year i don't the
exact exact tax brackets are but let's
just give a hypothetical
you're making 80k a year and they're
like okay we're going to pay you an
extra five grand
raise uh we're gonna pay you a certain
person
a five percent raise for you know so you
you get a certain percentage
but then that money is taxed an
additional five percent because you went
to a higher bracket you're not
really necessarily going to see that
raise you know what i mean if they tax
you on that
number all right let's see
janet partridge says 1972 produced some
good free thinkers cool guests
is that what 1972 that's your what did
they say you were born in 1972
yeah yeah they say they produce good
free thinkers oh wow
oh yeah the best ben walker says get tim
dillon on the show yes or yes
i think the question is whether or not
tim dillon will come on the show we're
well we're
like we have tons of people on the show
we have you know you know
all different types there's there's a
lot of very very famous people they're
like why don't you try getting you know
donald trump on the show it's like oh
yeah that's great i'll just get right on
let me call donald trump
alexander scarpecci says president is
the commander-in-chief
and within the chain of command of the
military and the protocol is to salute
the vice president is not but could
still salute out of respect well i don't
think she
respects anybody okay ethan sacco says
i'm a former marine
and all enlisted have to salute officers
no matter what officers can choose to
salute back if they want
we would all salute an officer
individually to piss them off and make
them salute back
well there you go
cameron lewer says can you talk about a
convention of states
it's super important and i think could
help save this country for a while
longer
so many people don't know about it
article five well there's a bunch of
different articles i guess yeah there's
different
uh like the states can convene and
change the constitution
really yeah you need a certain amount i
suppose yeah you do you like two-thirds
or whatever so
38 or something jeffrey park person says
alexander the great conquered the known
world by controlling four institutions
school religion art and media
entertainment sound familiar
people learn from histories man
sonny james says there's no selling
point for the left just fear and terror
right after a mass shooting the left
media likes
loved media like and a karen acting
badly please dox her
there might be some missing words in
there the left just like pandemics
racism in the fear for life
the invisible enemy forever who lives
like that crazy people i suppose
goosey goo says kick back with a glass
of bourbon listening to the show keep it
the great work guys your friend goose
thank you very much
appreciate it enjoy slurms mackenzie
says tim been a fan since you had like
18k
subs i'm from winnipeg and am a full
stack software dev would love to get
involved in what you're building
however i can remotely remotely of
course how can i make this happen cheers
well uh you can smash the like button
but i don't think we're hiring anybody
remote because there's so much
that we need to do here on the ground in
terms of physical infrastructure as well
as building things out
i'm not a fan of remote stuff i think
people need to be around each other and
share in a culture and ideas and help
things grow
and people who are in remote areas don't
interact with anybody else and then it's
like
it's like desynchronized you know let's
do a couple more super chats here let's
see what we got
wapo of epic says according to forbes
biden administration urges supreme court
to let cops enter home
and seize guns without a warrant it's a
violation of many amendments
and fundamental human rights gino fass
says please don't ditch me tim i'm a
website member i will not thank you
all right what else we got we'll do a
couple more michael ford says look how
successful you are now
think you could have accomplished this
in a uh could you could you have
accomplished this in a communist country
keep up the great show look forward to
it every night i could have
because they would have seen my
greatness and appointed me to the
position of
political speech propagandist
propagandist that's right
talk about the glory of communist
unendingly all right let's see last
super chat right here mike
graf says all women get guns concealed
carry permits and training free from the
government
even the physical disadvantage that they
have what do you guys think i agree
universal healthcare the government
should take over healthcare everybody
gets to go to the doctor whenever and
they also have to give everybody a gun
yes you get your choice
i think what do you guys think should
the should the standard firearm be a
glock or in 1911.
i'm leaning towards 1911. i'm gonna i
like the 1911 now
yeah i like the 1911 and uh maybe a
springfield armory 1911
and then but you also would have the
choice between the handgun
or the ar-15 and so
maybe maybe they offer you up like a
five five six so
the reason i propose this as well the
left wants
something they want universal health
care and they think they're deserving of
it because
they think it's a human right the
constitution says the right to keep and
bear arms will not be infringed and
conservatives want
guns so the compromise is okay then you
can have
universal health care for everybody
including the conservatives and the
conservatives also recognize that you
will get guns too
sounds great i'm in everybody wins and
we do this all with the money that we
get from the
millionaire movie stars that's right we
tax all the hollywood millionaires and
billionaires
and we use that to fund health care and
guns can i would not fund either of
those things but sure
can i still text the poor in my
neighborhoods
that i choose if they vote for you thank
you there you go
ladies and gentlemen before you leave
please do two things
smash the like button and subscribe but
actually do one more thing share the
show if you really like it
and leave a good review if you're
listening on itunes or spotify that also
really does help but uh engagement you
know commenting
liking subscribing all that stuff really
helps and um
we are weeks away from breaking one
million
yes subscribers on this channel so thank
you all so much to everybody
and for those of you that are members
over at timcast.com we're going to have
a a raunchy and profanity-laced bonus
segment coming up
just later in the night so go to
timcast.com become a member and for all
of you who are members you have no idea
how important you are
helping keep all of this running because
look ratings are down for everybody
across the board
ad rates are down for everybody across
the board it is the timcast.com
memberships that are renewing
this this operation and allowing us to
expand and do more things which we are
doing new website coming soon
and without your support this would not
be possible so thank you all so much
you can follow me on all social media
platforms at tim cast my other youtube
channels are youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comcastnews
this show is live monday through friday
at 8pm so thank you all so much for
hanging out erin you want to shout
anything out social media shows
uh my twitter is at ehrenberg comedy
instagram is the same thing
in hot water is live every day on
compoundmedia.com
2pm uh i will be at uncle vinnie's in
point
pleasant april 2nd and 3rd comedians of
the compound will be at standup new york
april 9th and just check my website
erinberg.com or compoundcomedy.com
and my store in hot water store has all
the great merch that you need
thank you nice you can follow me in
crossland.net
check out all my social medias there ian
crossland coming at you
i am sarah patch liz as you all know lit
not liz
i mean please don't call me liz and i
really appreciate reading all you guys
reviews on the podcast it's really kind
of interesting to go through we get
great reviews everyone likes us
believe me we're the best podcast i'm
real sourpatch lids on twitter and minds
follow me there
one day let me start over there's a lot
of people
who think they're too big to come on
this show and they say oh i'm so special
i'll tell you what one day this show
is going to be the biggest show and then
those people are going to be begging to
come on this show
and they'll be welcome because we're
reasonable people we don't hold grudges
but i really do hope
with your support this show becomes
bigger becomes better we improve
we bring on more and better guests more
people have real conversations so
tremendous thank you for all your
support and we will see you over at
timcast.com in our exclusive members
only segment
you